to hello everybody and welcome to the H3
podcast we are joined here by internet
Juggernaut internet Titan I'll take that
uh in our show many of you know him as
the I thought I was gay guy
but no he's so much more than that he's
so much more than that on Friday
Fouseytube is with us obviously and I've
always wanted to have you on the show so
thank you for being here thank you thank
you let's go
and on on Friday we had such a great
time watch it was so surreal that all
the comments were about like that fousey
clip was was this fousey segment was so
insane they lost her like three times
back we were trying to save your life
because you're going to live stream
through TSA checkpoint and I feel like
did we get through to you you did
um before I even say that though I want
to say thank you so much for even
addressing anything of me on the podcast
because what you've done for my subathon
right now like I can't thank you enough
like I did a poll today are you guys G7
members or H3 members and it was pretty
even so thank you so much for what
you've done absolutely thank you you
know I I say this man the the family the
H3 fam is they're strong they're very
supportive I didn't expect that yeah all
the years they're psychotic but they're
also supportive you did get through to
me because I was 100 gonna live stream
in the airport not with TTS super loud
but I was gonna let it go through the
security and everything well if someone
probably would have been like hey this
guy dressed like this is gonna do a
terrorist attack true yeah true true
true yeah yeah yeah so anyway oh thank
you to expressvpn for sponsoring today's
uh episode well you've been on the
internet for so long I mean you're one
of The Originals right I mean how long
ago
did you start making YouTube March 25th
of 2011 2011. wow like like that's why
people say like oh you're on the Mount
Rushmore of YouTube because you've been
there you've done that like I was on
there when Nigahiga and Kev Jumba were
still like doing their at-home videos
like early days
and were you doing pranks and all that
kind of stuff at first what did you
start when I first started so first of
all when I first started I was a Theater
Arts major at San Jose State University
and I won the best actor of the year
before came to visit the class I'm
expecting to hear I'm acting in this
movie I'm acting in this movie they
asked him what are you doing now he said
I'm working at a restaurant and I'm
doing auditions I panicked because my
brother was a doc uh surgeon my other
brother was a pediatrician my sister's a
lawyer and I'm like I'm going to be an
actor so I knew I needed to take it into
my own hands so I made a YouTube channel
but when I started I was doing Middle
Eastern skits like it was authentic it
was raw it was real it was talented
there was like class in it but then when
I moved to LA and I posted my first skit
it flopped and me like I panicked
because I'm like I moved to LA for this
it's my dream so I go out to shoot a
prank
I staged it oh from right from the
beginning right from the beginning okay
right off the rip right off jump I
staged it five minutes of work 30
minutes basically 30 minutes of work
recouped the value that I would have
gotten from a skit by 100. what was the
first one that you did that you faked
holding hands in public
or you just went up to people and held
their hand I just go up to the person
hey I'm doing a YouTube video can I come
up to you but here's the thing with me
because I was a theater arts background
I would direct them I would literally
tell them what facial expression to make
what to say how to act so were these
people you just found on the street or
you said you didn't pay them or anything
you're like hey I'm doing this video do
you want to do it with me if there were
times where if they asked to be paid I
paid as it got later on and I learned
from other YouTubers all the YouTubers
were faking their pranks from my area by
the way I'm the only one who took the
fall for it but every YouTuber faked
their pranks in that era right I think
we all come to to learn that I mean that
air is so far gone now it's just yeah
but yeah there was a point when everyone
was like dude all these uh pranks are
fake and then a lot of the pranksters
yourself included were like they're not
fake they're 100 real Vitality was
coke-filled rant about how he's
everyone's a phony he's only faked five
pranks
when they taught me how to fake pranks
when I got invited into the Inner Circle
at that time yeah and I I was like wait
y'all all fake your pranks and they said
yeah they taught me the method which was
posting a post on Craigslist getting 20
random people to come giving them thirty
dollars a pop yeah and so that's
interesting though that you faked it
from the very beginning because
I don't think you knew at the time that
everyone else was faking it right I
didn't so you you just figure I'm not
going to do this [__] well it's two the
thing is embarrassing my Persona as
fousey was so much different as to who
Yusuf is and the lines got so blurred
over the years because one overtook the
other but Yusuf like would never go up
to a person take his food like I've done
in some pranks eat it and get punched in
the face right that's just not me so I
faked it not for like I'm not gonna get
the reaction I want but I don't even
have the confidence to go out and do
those things it's a Ball Z yeah I mean
some of my videos I used to go out in
public and it's just so humiliating in a
sense I mean they're some of the best
videos we've made but I had to stop
because I was like it's emotionally it's
it's too painful for me to go out as
Vape Nation guy or whatever the [__] you
vape you don't right nah yeah that's my
first ever one let's take a look at it
two minutes so so this was just a quick
so this one I walked into the mall I
went up to the first person I said yo
I'm shooting this YouTuber he knew me
like fousey I'm shooting this YouTube
video can you be in my prank I'ma walk
up to you and hold your hand do exactly
this and you'll see play the first thing
actually can you help me out what's up
um can I see the Cincinnati hat oh that
one yeah right there what the hell is
wrong with you
it's funny watching it now it seems fake
because yeah I mean I could when you can
show me any prank yeah and I'll know
immediately if it's right for real right
immediately
hold my handprint but when I learn that
30 minutes of work could get me these
numbers and pay me this much I sold the
soul that's immediately quick money
immediately sold myself I wouldn't even
go that far I mean you're just making
entertainment videos no that's the thing
I always say this I got canceled for
fake pranks back when I got canceled as
harder than some people get canceled for
sexual assault these days you know I was
thinking I was thinking that today
because you know we've been talking
about Colleen Ballinger a lot and I was
like man fousey got like totally totally
dogpiled by the whole internet for
faking pranks and like not being able to
take criticism or something I don't know
what else but I was like dude Colleen
Ballinger was like sending
or was she sending she was sending
lingerie to 13 year old so I can say
that and she's on tour right now isn't
she uh she's done oh she's canceled
she's [__] oh it's done yeah she's
hella [__] but still she had all the
years of whatever yeah even I know
tick-tockers like there's this one
um Tony Lopez he like nothing happened
did you hear the call that got leaked no
pull that up dude it's [__] crazy but
what I'm saying is he did that and
didn't get canceled and I'm sitting
there like I I staged the prank which
made you laugh with made you comment and
said thank you for making my day I was
depressed and now I'm laughing but I got
it's whatever I'm over to be honest I'm
over it I don't cry about it at night
anymore uh yeah I'm sure you guys will
correct me if I'm wrong but I always
felt like you were unfairly treated by
uh the critics you know I I do and I
think I said that at the time it's like
he's not that bad of a guy you fake some
pranks and it'd be nice if you were
honest about it but everyone was faking
it and you were just making you were
just making a quick Buck which is fine
my mom always tells me when I go through
my depression or like when I left the
internet so many times she always said
this one line she goes Yusuf you've
never heard anybody else you've only
hurt yourself by your actions like July
15th nobody got affected by that except
for me my life was in shame what about
Drake
he was expecting that fat check he
wasn't going to get paid oh he was
coming for free he was coming he was
coming pro bono look if we talk about
July 15th on here I'm going to stand on
my ten toes and say Drake was going to
be there right now right now Drake you
were in touch with Drake you're still
saying that I'm I'm still sticking to
the story I found the guy who I ran into
in the club that night who gave me his
verbal agreement that he would be there
so okay a guy who knows Drake said he
was going to be there you want the story
right off the bat sure we're here why
not okay I cut us up a little bit with
what happened okay I'm setting up July
15th yeah I saw I was taking Adderall I
was in Australia I tried to do a tour it
had 30 350 people three years before I
had 3 000 people in stadium so I knew it
wasn't and everywhere I went on the
streets people were like Fouseytube
Fouseytube so my thing started with
I know that we had 350 people not
because only 350 people are willing to
support but because my manager at the
time did a shitty job in promoting so to
prove it I said I'm gonna fly to La rent
out a regular venue do a show sell
tickets by myself on the street and show
everybody that I like you know it was an
ego thing it ended up turning into
something huge long story short
we actually did get artists from all
over the world to fly in and they were
going to perform big artists like
hip-hop artists which ones which is the
biggest which was the biggest what's
that one guy he's bought OT Genesis I
think T Genesis yeah OT Genesis
so
the night before
I'm walking out of a restaurant and this
Paparazzi is out there waiting for me
because July 15 [__] and he go he after
the camera turns off he goes yo I know
where Drake is tonight I go tell me we
go to the club he says we go to the
doors Drake here no he's not here so we
leave Paparazzi calls back yo he's at
Delilah we get to Delilah my friend
tries to talk to security security said
you guys are not getting in tonight this
is a private event Drake writing out the
whole thing I told all my friends go
home I got this on my own
not going to tell every story detail by
detail I snuck I sneak into the club
through the back door that got open for
me I walk in it felt like an Illuminati
Cesspool every celebrity was in there
every celebrity you can think of was in
there I'm telling you Ludacris
um Kenny Hamilton like all these people
make sense of Drake's in LA and he's
inviting all of his friends yeah yeah so
I'm looking at everybody I'm walking up
to them yelling in their face like a
madman on Adderall dehydrated no ID in
my pocket I'm gonna do an event tomorrow
that's gonna end racism I'm gonna give a
bigger speech than the president has
ever given I was on one
stay there the whole night that
everybody leaves except for one giant
group Drake's Entourage and one random
couch with a bunch of IG models looking
like zombies just like this like waiting
to be taken home it was really weird
anyways I stand there waiting my legs
are shaking I'm standing I'm listening
to music I haven't seen Drake All Night
finally for the first time ever it's as
if the crowd split like this
and it was like open like whatever they
call that the river splitting and I see
Drake he doesn't see me but I see him
I'm shaking all of a sudden Drake's dad
walks by me I met Drake's dad at Tyler
Perry's movie premiere so I tried
tapping his shoulder to tell him can I
talk to Drake he's so drunk I go
whatever next thing you know the guy
who's escorting Drake's dad is behind
him comes up to me what did you want
I go on the most epic speech of my life
at the end of the speech he looks at me
in the eye and he goes I love everything
you just said but I have one question
for you I go what he goes how did you
know my name
swear to God I've never met this guy day
in my life and I go if your name came
out of my mouth that was from God like
psycho [__] okay I don't even remember
saying his name I don't know the guy
okay
he goes I put your number on my phone
we'll be there I save it under God's
plan next thing you know Drake is
walking out the club he's walking
towards me never looks at me never
anything but he says goodbye to Joelle
embiid right in front of me as he leans
in his nose is like right here my nose
is right here I don't stand it I don't
ruin the opportunity to be like Drake
Drake I leave the club I'm shaking I'm
going to Wild rant on my phone I text
one Juan G that was the guy's name he's
you guys can even search m1g the next
morning I wake up I text a picture to
Juan G a picture that says July 15th
with Drake's face on it the text said
scene or read
in my mind if I text you a picture that
I'm about to publicly promote and say
Drake is gonna be there if he's not
gonna be there you're going to tell me
stop it right now cease and desist what
are you doing you can't do this so I
sinned again oh my God I'm so excited
for tonight red oh my God this is so hot
because I changed my life red everything
going according to plan that's fun God's
plan then which wasn't God's plan was
not the plan he was shaped on all the
way this is the devil's plan next thing
you know the bomb threat gets called in
and you know the rest of the story and
then obviously Drake was never coming I
believe he was bro stop I personally I
swear to you I personally think Drake
was gonna be okay so you think that what
the biggest artist in the world
comes to the Greek Theater pro bono
because one of his homies was like
we'll be there the way I sold it right I
have a tick I have a show backed by
Ticketmaster and Live Nation it's in the
great Greek Theater 5 000 tickets given
out for free sold out look if he wasn't
gonna be there that's fine I know he
doesn't like me I got public like I got
actual word from people around this team
that came to me Drake does not like me
because I imitated him in that prank
another prank year later well you think
he knows you and doesn't like he does
know me and he doesn't like how'd you
find that out people from his team told
people that I know and the word got to
me so there's a lot of Correspondence
between you and Drake between some
people that might know him they know and
throw his team Drake doesn't like me I
promise you okay and look all you H3
family can be calling me idiot liar like
no no I don't think they're saying that
I'm just telling my honest truth I wrote
it in my book exactly how I just told it
I will never change that story ever and
if I ever do get the pleasure of meeting
Drake I'm gonna tell him that story
verbatim word for word so you came in
through the back and they never thought
they never tried to kick you out or
anything so there was a guy named lit
poppy he comes up to me outside the
outside Delilah and goes yo I was born
in South Central I don't want to die in
South Central put me on your stage
tomorrow yeah yeah like here put your
number on my phone I'll have my team
contact yours 10 minutes later the same
guy that was outside is inside the club
in the smoking section looking at me
through the bars hey come here come here
I run to the bars hey you want to get in
go to the back not a dog I can't do that
I can't sneak in you want to get in or
not
went to the back I see a Rolls Royce so
this that that next you know the kitchen
door opens I walk in I walk into the
club he walks me into the club he goes
all right everybody's here tonight have
fun I go how am I supposed to find Drake
he says GPS I go what's GPS he says
God's positioning system me being Manic
and hearing the word God I said oh my
God Allahu Akbar god listen to me so
were you you were you in a manic State
at that yeah yeah induced by Adderall
induced by Adderall so what I mean I I
remember the diagnosis at the time
seemed to be that you have like bipolar
and that you're in some kind of manic
state but but you said that was a mixed
diagnosis so when I was 18 I was in
college and I had my first nervous
breakdown I was in the library
opened my laptop next thing I know my
heart's palpitating I'm sweating I'm
like what the [__] is going on pack my
bags run home scared go in my room like
shivering go to the therapist for the
first time see a psychiatrist all it
took was I think one or two evaluations
and she goes yeah from what you said
you're bipolar and I took it I took it
around with it for my whole life even
took bipolar medication everything
2021 after the reality high incident
where I got knocked out by Bryce Hall I
get sent to a rehab in Karen
Pennsylvania and they do a 30-day
intense eval with many therapists daily
everything and at the end they gave me
my diagnosis and they said Yusuf you
have no signs of bipolar you're severely
depressed you suffer from depression but
no signs of bipolar and I and I've
always thought that because July 15th
was the only manic thing I've ever had
yeah you know it's highs and lows I
don't have any highs I only have lows
yeah I thought I thought you I thought
that myself because
um that clip of you is like you know the
thing about manic States is that I guess
you can be uh have delusions of grandeur
and all that kind of stuff so you are
experiencing that but you think it was
drug induced
I was experiencing that heavy you want
to know another story of July 15th sure
that night when I get home from the club
my girlfriend my then girlfriend at the
time opens the door to the Uber I look
at her and I say don't touch me don't
let anybody touch me there's something
inside me get everybody because I had a
whole Airbnb with all my friends I said
get everybody have them sit downstairs
I'm gonna go shower I go upstairs to the
bathroom I sit in the tub on my knees I
turn the water on let it drip on me it
felt like I was like possessed like
something was coming out of me this is a
whole separate conversation because I do
believe in like
Spirits energy and all that stuff but
yeah I I I just wasn't I wasn't mentally
saying and so now are you are you what
are you doing to kind of keep your
mental health in check my my fear was
when I saw you doing the 24 hour streams
back to back to back to back to back my
fear was that you might be going into
another manic stage because I mean this
the signs are there and obviously I'm
not diagnosing you I'm not a
professional even but the signs were
there in that it's like
super energetic super like on all the
time
um it seemed to me that that was my fear
basically is that you were gearing up
for for a manic like meltdown totally
understandable yeah
um so the last after the deji fight I
fell into the deepest again depression I
had ever fallen into this one was like
an existential crisis that was your
second or third boxing second and then
second time you lost I lost yeah
um and that one was the first one I
gotta say bro yeah
it's one of the I mean it's one of the
craziest [__] videos on the internet
the referee the the the coaches the
referee should have stopped it in round
one it should never have even made it to
round two but you're you just got that
fighter you wanna you wouldn't go down
yeah but you can tell that I was
defenseless
the announcers were like yeah no the
announcers were like freaking out but
you got you [__] up your nose from
that fight right you had to get face
surgery I've had three nose surgeries
but after that fight I got into such a
big depression I took nine months off
the internet I spent the entire the the
deji or the first one yeah I spent the
entire time in the East Coast with my
sister and family off social media
I did ketamine treatment for depression
I did TMS for depression TMS is like
when they give you
electrical brain zaps to wake up certain
neurons that aren't where do you get
that done
um there are clinics for it it's a seven
week thing doctor Monday through Friday
yeah it's just some dude with like
[__] I don't know but it all I know
is I did it for seven weeks five days a
week and this [__] worked really this
[__] worked I've done everything on
God's green earth for depression I've
talked to every therapist you can do
medicine I do I've been medicated for
over a year what do you take I take
right now Citalopram oh which is just uh
antidepressant and then for to sleep
though I have to take a medicine called
quentapine which is anti-psychotic but
at a low dose antipsychotics help induce
sleep nice
um I'm medic I'm heavily medicated are
you what do you take I'm on Lexapro and
well I don't heavily it's a pretty
normal like cocktail it's Lex bro and
Wellbutrin those are good that's a great
combo yeah it's helped me a lot
Lexington Wellbutrin is a good one I've
been on it for a few years and it like
changed my life dude yeah
it helped me so much so the meds have
helped you yeah I was always whenever I
took meds over the years the reason I
would stop so many times is because it
felt like a placebo I was taking it but
I wasn't able to wrap like actually see
am I different or not because I was
still depressed thank you man yeah this
time though after everything I've been
through at 33 nine months like this time
I was able to literally see and feel the
changes because over the nine months
I literally
oh man it was bad it was bad
go ahead no it was just bad man like my
my I don't know if it's cognitive
thinking but my brain just wasn't
working how it used to I'm a very good
eloquent speaker I lost my ability to
speak I lost my ability to converse with
people I would ask people like what do
you talk about in conversations my
memory became goldfish really bad like
it was really not working and over the
course of the seven weeks of TMS working
out in the gym gym is everything by the
way Jim is live without the gym I never
would have got it I couldn't agree more
without the gym I never ever ever would
have gotten out of depression yeah well
that's good I mean I I'm being a law
facie just because people know I make
fun of gym culture but if it helped you
that much you can be making fun of Jim
culture look how skinny you got I know
you're hitting the gym are you not no
really you don't know I'm not
anti-exercise I just think like there's
a culture of like these Bros these Alpha
Bros they're like the gym [__] cured
my cancer bro the gym brought my dad
back to life and he loves me now like he
never told me he loved me but it's like
the the but it helped you so I'm not
here I'm not here to uh my favorite
Little Gym always is what it does for
the mental health right like in one of
my favorite motivational speeches I
forgot who said I think it's brene brown
and she was like the first thing I want
you to do if you're depressed the first
thing is work out hit the gym the first
thing I want you to do literally the gym
and I when I finally after nine months
eating whatever I wanted every single
night feeling sorry for myself pity
party the minute I started going to the
gym and documenting it on YouTube before
the subathon slowly slowly slowly and
that's everything just well I think the
the importance of like feeling good
feeling yourself being healthy it does a
lot for your self-confidence and like
just your self-image you know that was
the biggest thing after the deji fight
yeah because I was so depressed though
you lost big deal
so the way I explained it in therapy
over the nine months was that event Not
only was it like I've always been
searching for a w after July 15th like a
win like life just give me a win and I
was never getting one
I was a brand new version I was sober I
got I've been sober since September 15th
of 2021 silver from what everything
what's everything well no it was
everything it used to be sex this is it
what is it that you were getting into
no just alcohol drugs
you said you had an Adderall
fueled uh psychosis or so so what kind
of drugs were you getting into no no the
hardest drugs I've ever done I've never
taken hard drugs
okay so just alcohol and Adderall
alcohol sex Adderall weed Adderall is
pretty [__] crazy drug to be honest
when I started taking Adderall before
July 15th the way I described it to
people was I finally felt like I was
supposed to feel in life like God how
God should have made me which is the
most taboo thing you can say God made
you exactly as you should be but I felt
like that was who I was supposed to be I
was talkative I had energy I wasn't
depressed I was able to work I wasn't
lazy but obviously I took advantage of
that and started abusing it
wait when are we talking about before
July 15th when I took out you were
feeling good you were in yourself oh
yeah and then you started taking
Adderall no no I started feeling good
because I started taking oh I see yeah I
I think I haven't [__] around with
Adderall a lot but it can give you like
a euphoric kind of like uh
self-confidence right so how many
Adderall were you taking leading up to
um I would pop like three a day 20
milligram extended release
I don't know and I was also drinking at
that time that's a bit and smoking weed
yeah that's a lot it just it was a bad
combination yeah but anyways I'm here on
h3h3 in 2023
I'm leaving the past behind me I've
talked about my sob story enough I've
I've talked about it anymore not July
15th and that [__] I want to just we
could talk about some stuff like we
could talk about the deji fight and what
that did oh I didn't explain that to you
well why why did that uh make you so
depressed so after I got sober I became
I think the best version of myself
physically and spiritually I was running
like 13 miles a day I was healthy I
wasn't consuming carbs I was a machine I
was a machine I was confident
the what the fight represented it wasn't
use of fighting it was fousey the ego on
His Highest stage think about it your
ego walking out 20 000 people booing you
your music blaring it was his final
showcase he got his ass beat fousey died
that day died so after the fight and
there was so much to happen after the
fight there was a lot of drama with
happy punch
um with your your bestie keemstar yeah
uh girlfriend left me uh got kicked out
of my house because the guy sold the
unit
um it was just thing after thing after
thing but most of all I lost my sense of
self and confidence I see I don't know
who the [__] I was anymore because I
thought I was the man I thought I was
the [__] I thought I was about to go and
knock deji out and become the King which
thank God I didn't because if I did I
would probably still be going down that
road but that night fousey died so for
the first time in 33 years I had to
figure out who Yusuf was the one last
thing the way I said it in therapy was
it's as if I had two plants one of them
I kept in the dark one of them I kept in
the Sun and watered every day Foos he
was being watered every day Youssef was
being left in the dark so when fousey
was gone all I was left with was a dead
plant and that was a hard pill to
swallow what's the difference between uh
fousey and uh
Yusuf
um
fusi
seeks approval wants to be liked will do
anything say anything manipulate himself
become a chameleon just to get that
validation that he so desperately wants
that he didn't get as a child and was
that born when you started that fake
prank and you saw the attention you got
from it about that or before then I
think it was finally because like I it
was
it was finally
I don't know how to explain it but it
was finally feeling accepted because I
never felt like I fit in even from a
young age I always felt weird and
different I always stood out from the
other kids because I felt weird why am I
overthinking so much
getting validation from the internet it
was finally like they like me they
really like me when they like you and
you want that validation you're going to
do anything to keep that validation
right so do you think that was part of
the where your personality split off
yeah yeah and what sometimes like you
lose sense of self yes yeah I've been
there I think everyone online goes
through that at a certain point and
there's like a crossroad in all of our
lives where we're like do we keep down
the online Persona or do we dig deep and
actually find send yourself a lot of
people come on YouTube and get burned
out because it's intense man knowing
it's it's finally like this type why the
subathon is so important to me is
because for once one I can't lie I can't
hide my emotions I can't act like I'm
someone I'm not my camera is on 24 7.
they see me for me and they actually
[__] like me so now it's like oh my
God so how do you know that you're not
going to
you know you're you're getting the
validation you're on all the time what
are you doing to make sure that you
don't you know go back down the path of
uh
overconfidence and ego and all that I
think I have
people to ground me this time because
before like when I was successful on
YouTube living alone in 1600 Vine Street
paying 13 000 for a penthouse but
calling it the world's most expensive
isolation chamber
um I didn't reach out to anybody I
didn't take advice from anybody not my
mom not my sister that's why they always
say we told you not to buy the Ferraris
we told you not to do this but I would
listen to nobody now I call my mom
almost every day my sister I talked to
regularly I have real people in my life
who really like will put me in check and
say yo see what's happening so you're
relying on your your family to keep you
grounded not just my family also my
audience there's a lot of people who
know me really well and they always like
send me personal [__] on the side if
they see something a little re but also
myself I hold myself accountable like I
told them during the subathon I said the
gym is the most important thing in my
life right now without the gym there is
no sabathon so I go to the gym every day
and make them watch me well I'm doing
what I need to do to sustain it
yeah that's that's interesting I just
it's like um
as you as you're enjoying all the
success on Twitch that's happening right
now yeah
and I see you're super hyped up and
excited about it yeah I would just hate
to see another collapse I know so I want
I just would like to see this is just
from the outside someone who's been
following you for a while
just to see something that's more like
maybe the problem is like it's too
energy like it's all like Bank Big Bang
super high energy instead of just kind
of like a sustainable kind of nice thing
that you can just do every day 100 the
problem with me and my entire career I'm
the king of starting something getting
great initial success and then leaving
it I had a podcast in 2016 called
mornings with fusi ended it after a
month and it was getting great
successful time I was overpaying my
staff I'm very bad at business so I
wasn't making money that made sense for
how much I was paying and me not knowing
business said
I shouldn't call an accountant or a
financial advisor and find out how much
to pay them I'm just gonna cancel what
were you paying them a lot like six feet
I was getting like he was he was jerking
me like he was jerking me okay
um gaming with fousey
um my mom's cooking channel my brother's
doctor's Channel my cat's Family Channel
I've always done something and done it
so well and then ditched it but also
it's because like you just said so fast
the part that worries me is the
intensity yeah because the success it's
it's never like this like even with
twitch it's been 19 days I have 20 000
subscribers 10 in the world in English
channels it's like this but I really
really like something deep inside tells
me that I can sustain it this time I
hope so I hope so or at least
you know there's there's no shame and
there's no harm or there's nothing wrong
with a gentle Landing you know what I
mean yeah like let's say it does it's
not as explosive as it is right now yeah
but you know what I mean you can glide
it doesn't need to be like a beauty or a
crashed or correct yeah my sister tells
me that all the time and I'm I'm gonna
listen to that and I know I'm very aware
I understand that what's happening right
now isn't like it's not normal not for
me not for twitch the way I explained it
to your team earlier and I explained to
somebody on the phone it's like if a
heavyweight champion loses his belts
gets depressed but then he gets one more
fight he gets the call he wins his belts
back that's what I feel like right now
this is a second shot at life I
literally I almost started Uber I almost
started working at Starbucks my life was
like [__] was done I feel like talking
huh you're Rocky you're Palestinian
Rocky yeah that's what's up bro
um
let me do um let me do an ad I only have
one ad yeah 30 minutes I'm just gonna
it'll take one minute and then we'll get
right back into it make that money but I
wanted to say real quickly um people who
haven't been on the internet forever
they may not realize what a big deal
fousey was at when you were at like the
peak of your prank uh Empire you were
one of the top sub channels you won
creator of the year that's where we got
the INF the the world famous uh I felt
gay no no that was that show of the year
the Year sure of the year was the first
year I won the top two streaming Awards
back to back creator of the year and
show of the year yeah and I told the
world I was gay finally and wait are you
gay no I'm not I felt gay
I'm not are you sure I'm straight okay I
know 100 would you
is there people in your life maybe
family members or distant relatives or
anyone who would judge uh you for if you
were to come out as gay and not that you
are I'm just curious in my family yeah
um yeah of course because I know like
and you know it's a it's a conservative
background right but with what I've done
already with the tattoos with the
piercings so unconventional for a
Palestinian Muslim to do this already I
would have no problem coming out and
telling them I was gay if I was yeah
that I know I know for sure for certain
I'm not gay
so why I just that speech is so awesome
I mean I know that you I don't know if
you don't like it or something but it is
there's something special about it you
know how much that [__] comment
ruined me why I just won the biggest
award but it was such a [__] moment
but it was bad you should have felt the
crowd oh it went from excited to yeah
because because it was pretty homophobic
and they're they were cutting to like
the gay the LGBT creators they like were
getting their reaction I felt gay and
like I went home that day and instead of
seeing congratulations it was just
Philip DeFranco this this and the other
and I'm like God damn it and then um
what did you mean by that though
I was just when you're on stage like
that you didn't prepare a speech or just
going off all the things I'm called okay
but I didn't mean to use it in a
negative con like I support the lgbtq so
hard it's so much closer to me than you
know but I can't speak about why because
you're getting close to me not me it's
very close to me very close to me and I
support it heavily Lucy's gay
Yusuf yes guys finally 2023 here on the
h3hd podcast I'm coming out I am
non-binary oh no I can't be non-binary I
just learned what non-binary was you can
be non-binary and gay uh yeah right yeah
non-binary just means you don't have
don't affiliate or that's it you can be
right guys you could be non-berry so I
admit when I'm ignorant towards
something I did not know what non-binary
means until my chat taught me so I'm
non-binary and gay there I said it
hell yeah bro I felt gay
I still don't know what to believe okay
let me think uh by the way here's um
here's Lily sings Who's bi right after
you said no way
no way me and her don't talk anymore
it's so sad
what's that me and her don't talk
anymore oh you guys besties we were
close when did you guys fall out
um
probably right after that show she had
the show yeah I followed that a bit Yeah
I worked out for her right right after
that no
hmm
it's a shame you know okay let me do the
ad I'm gonna stop saying that and then
we can jump back in but anyway thank you
to expressvpn that's right
yeah
[__] yeah
expressvpn listen
I used to spend again
I'm gonna read this copy they're making
me say I
um but you know they say I used to spend
over a hundred dollars a month streaming
services it's like okay some people do
that Netflix Disney plus Prime you name
it but since I started using expressvpn
I've been able to cut back and save so
much money every month
let me explain
uh all these different uh streaming
services like Netflix have thousands of
more shows than you think you just don't
see them all because they're showing you
only what you see on your country and
here's where we Stick it to the Man with
expressvpn
with the expressvpn you can change your
country of origin and get an entire
different catalog of Netflix shows for
example South Korea Italy it's all
happening and by the way I haven't said
this my mom is obsessed with South
Korean um
soap operas it's all she watches
actually yeah she's like a Stan
subtitled yeah super weird I was like
what I mean God bless I mean Stan BTS
forever but just didn't expect it cheers
my dude uh but using the expressvpn app
you can change your online location
expressvpn has over 90 countries to
choose from so every time you run out of
stuff to watch you can just switch to a
new country and unlock new shows
and I can't tell you how many times of
watching Netflix USA it's so [__]
boring same [__]
running out of [__] to watch there man
I would say I use Netflix
probably the least of all my streaming
apps now I haven't turned it on in ages
it's crazy I'm on like Hulu a lot even
the last Black Mirror season effing suck
bro I watched one episode I was like
hell it was so not Black Mirror I was so
pissed and I would search Twitter and
everybody was giving a rave reviews oh
really yes and I was I was like there
can't I can't be the only one I watched
the first episode
what was it about I remember thinking it
was just real dumb and I don't even
remember yeah it was bad
well anyway you don't have to get stuck
watching that crap anymore cuz you can
press VPN expressvpn you can go to Japan
unlock a bunch of anime a whole bunch of
Ghibli Studio you can go to South Korea
unlock
um all the South Korean pop to your
hearts content my friends I actually had
to use VPN when I was in Bali after July
15th when I ran out of the country yeah
I needed to watch porn and you can't you
can't connect in Bali no oh so you could
so you got the X the expressvpn porn
access
cheers my dude what kind of stuff did
you watch out there normal [__] just
normal [__] what does that mean
normal [__] yeah
I can call me weird as [__] they watch
just as weird [__]
oh yeah Joan is awful was the name of
the first episode and it was they were
streaming her live oh yeah the end was
just like what yeah went and broke a
computer I was like you know what's
awesome though I don't know if this is
on Netflix have you seen oh don't let me
forget it the Asian couple road rage
incident anybody know
beef that's one of the best shows I have
a watch okay years okay that's on
Netflix yes okay or it might be I'm not
sure hooked from beginning to end is
that good Olivia you've seen it
Rotten Tomatoes
okay wow crazy this is a beef ad
um yeah but here's the thing guys with
one click of the button expressvpn
changes your country of origin you
refresh the page and all your new shows
show up you don't need to pay extra
Apple TV or prime just to watch it and
on top of that I can even use expressvpn
to get discounts some Services cost less
than other countries oh [__] like if you
go to Netflix Argentina it costs like a
fraction of the price that's pretty
sneaky I'm going to Netflix Argentina
thanks to expressvpn and apparently uh
memberships cost like nothing in Ukraine
so oh man I'm actually changing I'm
going to Ukraine and you can do that
guys
um yeah at less than seven dollars a
month expressvpn pays for itself and so
much more so it's a no-brainer guys if
you want to get away get away to watch
more shows and save money while you're
at it go to expressvpn.com H3 don't
forget to use my link so you can get
three months for free that's exp r e s s
vpn.com H3 expressvpn.com H3 to learn
more thank you to our sponsor thank you
thank you everybody
yeah [__] yeah
congrats on that I haven't gotten a
brand deal in like two years really I
don't get why if you make content that's
like yeah especially like right now I'm
all in the gym I'm documenting my weight
loss Journey I've had a fantastic
results already you would think that I
would get a gym sponsorship I shave
every on this live stream I've shaved
for the last 19 days it's been 19 days
it takes time and we've been doing this
for years it takes a long but it's been
I'm telling you it's been it's been a
while yeah but I think that's also
because of how I'm transmuting that
information I'm putting out in the
universe all the time I don't get brand
deals I never get brand deals you work
with somebody I do but if you say that
you're gonna get exactly what you're
saying do they suck no they're actually
very good for a lot of other clients I
think they're just having trouble
I don't know working it out yeah it
makes sense you'll get there so let's
take a look here let's see all right I
want to ask you about the IRL streams
and all this stuff let's go okay
not not to be a hater yeah but so when
we first tuned into your stream there
was some skepticism here in the office
oh it's gonna call all y'all
who backed
me for sure it's fake who said that
I'm gonna say I'm gonna name names just
for the sake of the conversation yeah it
was it was
it was love and it was a b but a B's
come around well hold on no but it was
all part of the journey it was all part
of the journey dude because I'll tell
you this they were like it doesn't make
sense why does he have so many Subs his
views are like he's at like 1 000 and
he's got like 15 000 Subs it doesn't
make any sense and then uh love checked
the public records yeah and he said oh
[__] it's real so so we did these guys
they're they're with you now well I was
saying I wasn't sure but I was I was
mentioning how the top donator was the
same dude but again this is before that
that's what I wanted fully G7 so that's
what I want to ask you so you've got one
guy his name is um Vivid Alchemy yeah
Museum who he's donated
um it seems like he's donated like 90 no
way not nine fifty percent uh I wouldn't
even say 50. I'd say a little under that
do we have a number on that at all yeah
do we have his final number I'm not sure
I know he's dropped over fifty thousand
dollars
who the [__] is that so I get into
marketing company I get an email one day
yeah he owns I get an email one day and
I get these emails all the time so I
disregarded it it said can I train you
in the gym I've been kind of trading
with you in the gym can you train me I
don't reply I I don't know why uh see I
shaved and I don't get a single I don't
get a single shaving brand deal yeah we
got to get you that deal so vivid Vivid
um he asked me to train him in the gym I
disregard it he emails again and says
I'll even pay you I'm trying to be a
personal trainer at the time I have a
fitness app that just came out I'm like
bet he's gonna pay me let's do it
he comes down
I train him he takes me to BOA
Steakhouse that night on him and then he
goes Yusuf for you I want to do this he
gives me 3 500 in cash and since then
for training him no no just for training
him he paid me no that was separate that
was separate how do you owe you 3500 for
her he just gave it to me as a gift who
is this guy I see like he's been a long
time fan he said without where's his
money he said without me he wouldn't
have started his business been able to
buy his mom a home and everything so he
wants to give back I've asked him
personally privately why are you doing
all this because it scares me it's like
if you're doing all this and then you
leave I'm scared
um and he was like listen Yusuf I want
to invest in you you've been there
before I know you're going to get there
again I just want to get people excited
I just want to motivate people and
recently he actually told me he was done
donating and I said Vivid that's fine I
was like you don't even have to gift 50
every single time you want to get people
excited just gift one and get the hype
train going and he said he was done I
understood we had a conversation I'm
going on a trip with them to Guatemala
this year and then now he's still been
going like this morning he gifted like
400 Subs okay so you do know who the guy
is I do his name is Nadeem because some
people were having these theories that
because he it's on Reddit yeah people
are just speculating about it this is
our subreddit oh that's awesome
um that he because he's I guess Vivid
Alchemy is a digital marketing agency
and a bizarre one at that like we did a
little bit of research his network is
all dentists yeah he actually just got
me a brand deal with a dentist in
Houston what yeah well actually I lied
about not getting a brand deal I just
did it why would a dentist in Houston
sponsor you that's so Random so I was in
Houston for the weekend yeah visiting a
friend
uh Vivid worked with a dentist in
Houston called him hey yusuf's there the
dentist has teeth whitening kits he's
still promo your teeth whitening kits
trust me he has a lot of motion on
Twitch right now do it I did it nice so
you filmed it already but is it out yet
the brand deal yeah no so you're like
come to this one specific dentist in
Houston yeah wow but he works with so
what I'm going to Guatemala for I can't
say yeah we're doing a humanitarian type
trip it's actually teeth bro I knew it
was going to be a billion dollar smile
[__] no no no no that was Colombia I
think yeah it was Columbia that was the
worst [__] ever I mentioned it to you
before but I've been I love the billion
dollar smile Adventure you went on with
why do you like it so much dude it's so
[__] funny like it's just so odd like
you guys went out to Colombia and the
teeth that he gave you guys is and no
offense your teeth look beautiful now
they looked absurd yeah I mean they
looked [__] nut like a piano keys and
to everybody wondering so I and you
could go to Columbia get your teeth done
for cheap I got it done for cheap and
then all of them turned yellow and all
of them like decayed it was the worst
thing I'd done and you paid half how
much did you pay him 2500 so it's 5 000
for the whole thing
yeah because the way he does it I guess
when people do like the serious way they
shave your teeth down right they do
shave your teeth but not only that they
don't just put like composites on your
teeth they get actual teeth made from
the manufacturer like you get actual
like veneers have to be of quality you
just puts plastic porcelain on that's
what I was like he does he just puts a
little like sticker on the front I was
like there's no [__] way this [__] is
real how long did it take before your
teeth started like decaying off a month
one month one month and it was yellow
and I sent him pictures did he respond
to you ever yeah I'm so sorry brother
this never happens come back I'll fix it
for you did you ever Google his name
because I did after I watched that Vlog
and there was it was just like a hundred
percent better no I used to be so
impulsive that when I get an idea in my
head that's it there's nothing that can
stop me I'm there I'm going I'm doing it
although the guy had weird credentials
because I saw videos of like Kanye there
and all kinds of like celebrities why
the [__] would they go to takash
but why would he go to so do you think
maybe he gave you the [__] to you I
don't know I don't know Alex hated it
too Wasabi came with me poor guy I
ruined Wasabi's teeth to get him redone
his [__] was bad too I think he gave you
guys the [__] teeth I don't know maybe
he probably saves the good [__] for
Takashi and Kanye you know we were
YouTubers though yeah but he took us out
that weekend
he did everything
you guys you guys carne asada like
Connie when you get invited to the carne
asada it's like when you get invited to
like the function oh the barbecue we got
lit we were drinking we were partying we
were having a good time
although he still charged you for half
which is not that doesn't speak clout to
me
yeah he's like you still got to pay me
2500 for this [__]
I hate when people like when I walk into
a place and people think I have money
like even now right now I don't have
money I'm blessed this month but I even
called my brother on the way here and
said I'm gonna make this much this month
how much should I invest here goes Yusuf
don't invest any of it exactly keep it
in the bank he said Yusuf you understand
that like 40 of that is going to taxes
you haven't made money yet wait for a
year of sustained income before you
invest after you do your taxes and
everything but at the time like now if I
go into a place an establishment like a
jeweler they think oh fousey has money
so all of a sudden the price goes from
here to here well you think people are
sharking oh yeah always always
So when you say invest like what do you
mean like where do you want to put that
money so I made millions of dollars
throughout my career Millions
I have zero to show for it I made zero
Investments zero I didn't buy zero
properties I didn't open up a single
business so I just mean use the money to
make more money let me invest in a
portfolio let it stay there let me buy
property my financial advice to you is
if
if you have less do you like in your
situation because it sounds like you
don't have a lot of money in the bank I
would just keep it in the bank bro
it's not enough if I told you how much I
had right now your job would literally
drop how much
under a hundred you have under a hundred
dollars hundred thousand oh see where
you speak in a different language then
yeah phenomeners under a hundred
thousand but to me after having that's a
lot of money and my upkeep to live in
L.A just for my house my health
insurance my car my no I know it's
expensive ten thousand but that's a lot
of money yeah so is that leftover money
from the Heyday that you're still living
off of there so there were so many
different ways I went broke one time
before and I ended up selling the house
that I bought for my parents in New
Jersey With Their Blessings because they
moved to San Diego so nobody's using the
house so I got about 350 000 from that
sale
and that was right when I got out of
rehab in Pennsylvania okay and I stopped
drinking vaping smoking sex masturbation
massage Parts I stopped everything right
so I needed people masturbating is free
I have a sex addiction
so masturbating to me is different than
a normal what is masturbating mean to
you
well let me just say this
um so after getting that 350 000 and I
gave up all those stuff my obsession
became spending so I spent that 350 000.
oh wow see that's a and not to go back
to the bipolar thing or I guess to go
back to it I know that um
compulsive spending is also a symptom of
like manic moods yeah so I don't know if
you go through that where you just spend
all your money I used to but now it's
like I'm able to like be oh like you're
not bipolar I'm the cheapest person on
earth now now don't get me wrong if
somebody's in need like the other day I
was in Walmart a TTS came off and it
said give this 500 to the cashier this
poor old man this father who was working
there his dopamine probably shot up to
the sky I look at the donation it was
five dollars I immediately said what's
your cash app and I say I'm 500. so I'm
only but I'm cheap and like
uh in Houston I bought two girls drinks
just for fun for the stream I thought
drinks were gonna be ten dollars I don't
drink no more there was 24 per drink no
both five thirty two like I never used
to count this thing it's not like it
used to be I used to be like a Nicki
Minaj song don't look at the tags just
swipe the card now I'm actually
conscious now you look at the tags don't
swipe the card yeah now my brother
literally on the phone right now what
does masturbating mean to you you got me
intrigued by that so when you have a sex
addiction like it's not just like I I
asked that in therapy a lot I was like
my friend [__] a different girl every
night why is he not an addict and why am
I an at it sounds like he is an addict
yeah but there's there's a lot of uncl
on I you know sex is messy
psychologically but for me like
masturbation sex it's like it's filling
in a deep deep deep emotional hole and I
have a reason do you know the reason did
you ever see it's in my book people no
go ahead I love to find out I'm a child
child okay under 10 years old everybody
at school is talking about masturbation
sex all this stuff I'm like what the
[__] is that I live in a conservative
Muslim household
I go home one day
first time ever take off all my clothes
I had a life-size toy leopard that you
can win at a carnival sitting there and
get on top of it I start humping it with
Miss Congeniality on the TV when I came
for the first time ever ever my Muslim
mother opens the door and sees me
ejaculating holy [__] dude how old were
you under 10 I think so that was
whenever Miss Congeniality came out I
was born in 1990s so you could do the
math that was my first experience that
it gets worse it gets worse that's
pretty traumatic she yells at me and
tells me to put my clothes on and closes
at the door
didn't talk to me that whole night that
next morning I sent her an AOL email and
said Mama I'm sorry the devil got on my
head that won't ever happen again she
replied to me in an email and said
you're right Yusuf the devil did get in
your head this is why you need to pray
comes home from work that day never ever
ever addressed it so from that point on
anything sexual anything like ever like
whatever to me I'm a bad person I'm
wrong I'm guilty I'm shameful that
caused literally it affected all my
relationships because that's what caused
my severe are you mad at your mom for
that I'm not I forgave my mom my mom did
her best that she can right and what she
knows now granted if I could have had it
my way my sister's sister-in-law her
kids were with her in bed young kids one
of them started playing with his penis
she looks at him starts laughing and
goes baby that's totally okay what
you're doing but you can do it in bed
with Mom he's gonna grow up to live a
nice healthy life that me I went up
thinking if I get a boner I'm wrong the
devil's in my head I can't do that
that's crazy and that caused 10 years of
premature ejaculation
so you would you know how my mom caught
me on the second I came yeah so the
second
you would even do this to me outcome
it was a traumatic response so any
slight
um any slight uh sensation would make
you come so slight so my first time
losing virginity I didn't even get
inside her before I came
um it got to the point where a friend of
mine told me hell my God I just went
under the massage parlor and guess what
she did I said what he goes she jacked
me off my mind lit up not because I can
go get a free handoff jack off but no no
not because I could go get like a jacked
off but because I was like this is
perfect I can go practice lasting longer
in private and so you did that and then
go perform so I go there the first time
I ever went I go
tells me to turn around towels over me
I'm naked I'm rock hard all of a sudden
I feel this
I'm like no [__] way he slapped your
chest yeah my eyes are still closed she
goes like this I open and she goes you
want I'm like yes the second the second
she put oil on me and touched me I came
she started laughing at me so I left now
I feel even worse than before and that
cost 10 years of massage parlors wow
that is interesting man I gotta say yeah
I mean the first time ever orgasming and
your mom walks in and tells you you're
possessed by demons that's pretty that's
pretty you have to pray imagine what
that did for my relationship with my
religion it was so conflicted you know I
I don't
I don't know a lot about the Islam a b
obviously is our is Islamic and I've
heard from him you're Muslim yeah yeah
no he's Lebanese
I'm with you yeah yo hey B I loved you
so much
oh my God he's white passing right
that's what he says about himself yo I
love you baby love you too bro
a little bit way
yeah I love you guys can you be my
parents yeah we'll adopt you oh my God
just as long as she doesn't have to walk
in on you masturbating right you know
that is so awesome
is telling me stories about how his
grandma's always telling him I didn't
know that like Islam was all about like
devils and hell and [__] I didn't know
that because in uh in Judaism hell
doesn't even exist it's not even a thing
right and so Amy's been telling me about
how his grandma used to torture him with
stories about him going to hell for all
eternity and [__] and I was like holy
crap that sounds traumatic yeah sounds
pretty heavy duty to be telling kids
that stuff yeah that's why like me and a
lot of my cousins are [__] up because
we all thought we're going to hell
anyway so we're like [__] it but uh yeah
like the first time my grandma met Lena
and she's wearing a sleeveless shirt she
told Lena the the devils are gonna rip
your arms out of your sockets and drag
you through it all yeah that's so gnarly
that's wild how did you react to that
Lena
um I just I was being polite and I'm
like
just yeah just normal I guess I don't
know that's your face yeah yeah and I
understand Arabic so I knew what she was
saying to me have you have you ever had
someone talk to you like that before oh
yeah yeah not that directly but like
I've had an amp before Tommy because she
was shopping with us and I picked out a
dress that was like sleeveless and she
kept trying to talk me out of it and I
she was like fine burn in hell oh my God
yeah so normal if I ever get a
girlfriend by the way you two are my
double date couple every time oh so
honestly and then you guys can tell me
if she's good for me but they're a good
wingman yeah they're good people I do
not know this they're great so awesome
yeah I love AB by the way he's been my
biggest supporter on this subathon hands
down I love it he's one of the best them
and Lena are both incredible they're the
best the best that the best there is out
there thank you thank you you too thank
you Ethan thank you I also come fast too
so we got that actually is that right
but I've tried everything to get here
well I want to learn about that but
actually I'm interested in av's coming
habits now
when I was younger yeah I just I always
get so anxious uh so I'm already shaky
and like it didn't help when I think of
anxious and sex I feel like not getting
it okay I feel gay
I feel like I would when I get anxious I
wouldn't be able to get it up not come
immediately I felt worthless
but you but so your guy's response is
just to come immediately
sucks man it ruins so many relationships
that man that that's that's painful that
it really is and it's humiliating it
stops you from even wanting to say hello
to a girl and this is as early as
College I wouldn't even approach a girl
because in my head I would be like I
approach her because I'm good my
personality she would like me would good
I'd be like we meet we go out to eat she
likes me but eventually it's gonna get
to sex I'm gonna do one pump fousey and
it's over so okay tell me this if you've
been in a long-term relationship where
you guys are having sex on like a daily
or you know multi-weekly basis does it
ever get better yeah when you're with
the same person yeah it gets better okay
like for me going to massage parlors why
it's so exciting I had this favorite
spot of mine I can't believe I'm talking
about this I want to know everything but
I trust you and your audience H3 family
we won't tell anything y'all with this
we won't tell anyone so I went to this
spot that was Full Service what does
that mean they have sex whoa yeah is
that in L.A yeah whoa that's full I was
like what is full service everywhere in
La everywhere so I went to this place
and the excitement for me I would always
tell don't wait are these women like sex
trafficked do you ever think about those
who work regular jobs one girl would be
like we would talk what do you do oh I
work here oh you just do this at night
yeah it's my second job so they're
Americans
no all kinds Asians Hispanics blacks
everybody so it's a prostitution spot
yeah all over La whoa it's rampant is
there a way to tell which ones are and
which ones aren't I could tell just by
looking on the outside so what so so
what is it that gives away what's the
difference
you could just see like it just looks
like just doesn't look right why is
there a massage spot next to Little
Caesars in this random parking
and then you walk in and everywhere on
the walls it says we do not do sexual
services do not ask you will be kicked
out oh this is such a lie because my
fear is that I go into a massage spot
and then it's like a sex spot and I
don't and I'm just there for a massage
you could just say no
so I've never been propositional she
does this slaps my cause I know yeah but
the reason I like going to the spot I
went to I wouldn't even pick because you
can say I want to see the woman and they
come in like Rush Hour like the movie
yeah I would say surprise me so I would
be laying on this table anxious
depressed guiltful shameful everything
but it's the process of addiction but I
would be so excited not knowing who was
gonna walk through the door and all of a
sudden door opens five foot four Latina
huge butt huge tits wearing this dress I
didn't last even there but I would
always tell them that would be my first
line I finished very very that makes
their job easy they probably loves you
oh they do yeah they're [__]
discounts at me though some a lot laugh
at me laughed at me I don't go you don't
like the Laughing no it's so
embarrassing it's humiliating yeah I
don't go anymore though but yeah
so this is very interesting to me how
often are you going to the massage
parlor
so
when I first moved to LA and I was like
by myself drinking every night before I
even started the pranks I was like it
was my only place of comfort so it
became when I was happy I would go and I
was sad I was going I was stressed I was
go I would literally there was a time
Logan Paul Jake Paul George Janko
everybody lived next door to me when I
lived in the house I remember the day
vividly George Janko was in my place you
said for me Logan Jake were all going
out tonight come before Logan even
started YouTube oh nah dog I can't I got
to be up early tomorrow he would leave I
would get in my car I would go to the
massage parlor so it was a real problem
yeah you start skipping the your real
responsibilities you're real like I
would be driving to a meeting
once it once you go on autopilot and it
takes over without even being able to
control it my hand's doing a YouTube oh
wow I'm in a massage parlor I missed the
meeting so sorry I overslept oh wow so
how many times a week were you doing
that it depends because with an
addiction you would think like oh you're
a sex addict you must have sex a hundred
million times a week you can literally
only go once a month and still be an
addict because there are times the the
circle of addiction you get the idea you
start ruminating on it you start getting
excited that idea turns into action you
go you do the idea and then you feel
guilty shameful remorseful hate myself
I'll never do this again I will never go
again I'm done I'm done that's how you
felt after every time every time that
could last a day a week two weeks three
weeks sometimes a month but all of a
sudden the rumination comes back and
it's as if you never told yourself you'd
never do it again and you're back doing
it a lot of men have that same problem
with masturbation you don't believe how
many emails I get from people Yusuf I'm
so shy to say this I don't know how to
stop masturbating I tell myself to stop
every night but I do it again and what's
the problem in this case they're just
doing it too much they just don't want
they they it's not they don't want to be
doing it has control over them once
something has control over you right and
you no longer have control it's a
problem see I I'm personally Pro
masturbation I understand it can be a
problem for some people but I think you
know sex is stigmatized in a lot of
cultures and it's so natural and normal
for people to do it I masturbate now
like I jacked off on my live stream
yesterday on it I took my sleeping pills
right yeah I'm exhausted I mean they
know that is this yeah it was 6 p.m yeah
I took my sleeping pills yeah I'm out
I'm like delusional all of a sudden out
of nowhere I don't even remember saying
this I wake up
I haven't jacked off for so long because
this damn subathon I'll be right back
y'all I need to take a [__] I put it on
mute went to the other room 30 seconds
later I was back that's all it takes
that's all it takes for you yeah
you used to have like a baby yesterday
too I slept good baby watch your ass
sleep yesterday
so how many times a week or a month were
you going it wasn't on a weekly basis it
was on a daily basis
depends there were times going period
like going on a Monday then a Tuesday
was very rare okay very rare going on a
Monday going on a Thursday going on a
Sunday I see that's more a few times a
week yeah and how much is it when you go
do that so cover charge 50. that's just
to get in and then to the girl at the
place I was going was 120 but I had so
much money at the time what the [__] is
that 120 to have sex or get a handy I
have sex that's handy that's really a
handy I could get for 40. and if they
try to charge you over 40 they're trying
to hustle that seems like a bargain I
mean I don't know anything about like
prostitution I thought it was more
expensive and their imagine how packed
this spot is is it oh my God go out any
time of the day there's a guy walking in
and a guy walking out holy [__] do you
guys the only one no I only [__] I'm
not getting out go ahead only difference
between you and I is I am open about my
history my past my sins so you're
watching me to do huh who are you
talking to anybody oh so you but I don't
think everybody's going to massage
parlor no no but what I'm saying is
everybody has their own skeletons in the
closet yeah everybody has their own
demons yes the only difference between
us being public they're out for the
world to see yes but don't leave a
comment acting like you don't have your
own skeleton like you never said we are
not perfect for a second yeah
obviously some skeletons are worse than
others but yours I don't I don't think
yours are really anything to be ashamed
of I mean you don't you didn't really
harm anyone but yourself and all the
women you know all the women I've ever
met have always said you are so kind
because think about how many guys they
get drunk guys angry guys forceful guys
aggressive guys I'm so respectful and
you come fast yeah I'm so respected in
and out and they always say you're so
handsome because my smile yeah they say
I'm so nice I don't go anymore though
no I believe you yeah I'm just super cat
I've never talked to somebody with like
this I never used to be this open about
it it used to be the scariest thing in
the world for me yeah because you
shouldn't I don't think you shouldn't be
embarrassed I mean you gotta own
everything yeah that's how I live if I
didn't own it and come to terms with it
and like be able to talk about it I
never would have got past it because I
always would have been hiding it and
that was the problem for so many years
when I got big doing the skits people
thought I was like the poster boy for
Muslim kids in America so families loved
me look at this kid he prays he's from
Palestine he's Muslim and he's
successful so when they start seeing the
tattoos and seeing me drunk and weed and
this it warped but for years I was
living a double life I was living as the
Muslim poster boy but then behind the
scenes going to a massage parlor right
it was hard to deal with yeah
so you it's kind of funny you'd be in
there with a bunch of dudes you ever
look at each other like well no no no
never make no eye contact nevermind were
you afraid someone would recognize you
all the time people have before on my
way out yo or what are they like yo
fousey are they like what are you doing
here I paid for me before a fan paid
fan paid for me he went to the did you
say thank you you accept it thank you
yeah thanks bro he said he said I wanna
I'll pay for his too he paid I was cool
with it that's who that's how you treat
a home man yeah
but it's a serious problem and I know
for a fact there are people watching
right now who suffer with it might not
have to be massage parlors it might be
masturbation but I know there's people
who are going to benefit from this
conversation and realize they're not
alone because the worst thing in that
situation is when you feel like you're
alone right that's that's one of the
reasons I'm very open with my mental
health that I've I've been through
anxiety depression I'm medicated because
um it's still stigmatized even in this
day I mean especially in this Alpha bro
culture it's like there's this attitude
amongst a lot of men in particular that
uh you know getting treated for
psychiatric problems is weak and that
you need to be able to just handle it on
your own and it's just it's just not
true on my Heyday on YouTube I was
speaking of Howie Mandel and he's always
friend of the show love him oh really
and he gave me the one of the best
advice ever he goes Yusuf I put all my
kids through therapy whether they're
happy or sad I tell them they especially
need it if they're happy good man he's a
good I love Howie he's such a good guy
yeah he's one of the nicest guys man
that's nice
um
yeah a friend of yours actually once
famously said if you're depressed just
take three sips of beer who said that
keemstar
Daddy
pretty insane right isn't it crazy that
out of all people who I would become
BFFs with and business partners it would
be Keem it is
I always felt like that relationship was
almost like a
I don't know that that you were even
consciously aware of it
but I felt almost like it was a just
please bro I'd rather be friends than
enemies just leave me the phone alone
yeah 100 that's what I was it was would
I want to be enemies with my enemy or
best friends with my enemy but you can't
really be friends with keemstar because
he he he he does have a some kind of
personality disorder in my opinion that
he like if you slight him in the
stupidest way he'll like turn on that's
fine but when I'm gonna say this about
Kim when Keem rides for you when Keem
likes you he [__] rides for you this
guy texts me like the other day I sent
him a clip of the July 15th of me crying
about on stream and I said post this on
drama alert instead of saying yeah yeah
100 is going to get numbers he said are
you sure you want me to post this I said
what do you think he said I don't think
you should
what did you want them to post I cried
on stream about July on July 15th this
year I finally let cries out and I I
sent him the clip and he didn't want me
to post it so when he wrote you didn't
think of it he writes for you but I'm
gonna admit this you know what I said in
therapy about him before when I was best
friends with him I said I feel like I
became best friends with my abuser
that's what I that's how I felt it was
almost like a Stockholm thing that's
what I that's I I had to deal with that
in therapy for a long time because my
relationship with him like I was on top
of a car saying you made me want to kill
myself yeah but I want to say King
treats me really good and he really
cares for me he does yeah until you say
something just a little bit off and then
he tries to ruin your [__] life I I
really I I really don't think like even
me talking about this on the podcast I
don't think he's gonna no I don't think
so you're not saying anything wrong
about him
okay [__] but uh anyway I just thought
that was funny not the not the greatest
mental health advocate he is
you know
well he knows depression's real now
that's what he says
whatever I don't really care about kids
when are you getting in the boxing ring
with them that's not happening ever why
would I even like
come on why would I even dignify that
that's just like why would I even get in
the ring with him he's so irrelevant
but you but think about what it's going
to do for you you're going to get into
the best shape while you're that's good
yeah but I want to do it with keemstar
okay you know maybe Drake Is On My Level
if maybe you could get connected
I got a couple of words just a
free-for-all I swear so um
okay so your sex addiction seemed like
it was more about like the
masturbating slush handies or were you
sleeping with a lot of people as well I
wasn't sleeping with a lot of people
yeah okay so is it different it was a
different than what you think of you
know I know I know a few people who are
sex addicts and I don't think people
realize how devastating this addiction
is it the people that I've seen who are
sex addicts
they cannot maintain a relationship they
lie about everything they hurt so many
people it is really really really such a
damaging addiction for them and the
people around them that I don't think
people realize that you know that's why
the first time I went to rehab I think I
was
28 and it was for my sex addiction
nobody knew why I was going I didn't
even tell anybody but all the men there
were older they all looked at me and
said good on you for being here this
young good on you because they were like
65 still going yeah probably their whole
life was ravaged from it it's it's such
it's so
when it takes control over you it is so
it's it's wow it's unbelievable I've
never felt that type of autopilot in my
life right and so how did you get uh
control of it
years years years
um finally doing the proper therapy
finally understanding why am I like this
I know I'm like this but why when did
you unveil that Mom Epiphany in therapy
yeah yeah yeah were you like oh [__]
when you like kind of put it together no
because I always
I always like knew but I didn't like I
just didn't piece it all together but
when I finally understood and also by
understanding it what did that mean to
little Yusuf like go have a conversation
with that little kid would you tell him
what you're telling him yourself now
right I wouldn't of course so you start
treating yourself Kinder you start
gentler with you gentler with yourself
but also going to meetings help
tremendously that's interesting because
you get to hold yourself accountable
you're meeting with a similar man going
through the same problems you could be
vulnerable you could be open you could
be held accountable and it just you know
I've I have a good friend who went to
who goes to meetings regularly for
alcohol and he says the same thing that
these meetings are like uh meetings too
yeah yeah so to anyone listening I think
I think these meetings are really
impactful for people trying to change I
haven't had sex in a year
what about masturbating not oh well you
masturbate the other day yeah but I
haven't had sex in a year
hey do you think you'd finish Fast if
you did 100 yeah and I but I boom you
know what I used to say
obviously what I used to say to girls
I'm just sorry you're just so hot yeah
that's better but then I started but
then I started being honest and saying
hey I finished very quickly the first
time please bear with me what if you
went and jerked off in the bathroom
before it doesn't matter try that
doesn't matter try that oh I've tried
everything I've tried pills I've tried
numbing cream I've tried bathroom condom
Pebble condom wrap it up everything wow
that's a that's a really unique
interesting problem she could blow on me
too hard and I'd finish right
but when I get a wife like the air like
not sucky like blowing there yeah but
when I get a wife obviously this is
gonna I'm gonna have to tell her about
everything and it's gonna be the first
thing I do tell her if I'm serious about
her hey I suffered from this this is
what I have the first time we have sex
I'm gonna finish very fast I hope you
don't judge me I hope it's not like I
hope you're not upset and I'll get
better and I know it'll be fine so when
you're in a long-term relationship are
you like normal or is it still short
long-term relationship yeah normal it's
normal yeah you can go have a normal
session yeah that's good yeah
takes a while to get oh my God my last
action I was a porn star how long does
it take you to get to a normal place
um I gotta get familiar with her not
only on a physical level but on an
emotional level too once I get to know
her and we feel connected I'm much more
but my last ex I was really good there
you go see see ladies really good
yeah why I got so that's good I mean I'm
just fascinated because you're so open
with this stuff yeah you feel that AB
oh yeah
good for you brother no I'm I'm you guys
have so much in common
[Laughter]
um
okay I want to ask you about the
keemstar house tour why did you erase
that that was such an iconic video it
was funny because when you guys were
saying that on the podcast I was like I
never erased that it was on a channel
called fousey one of the 20 channels I
made biggest mistake of my that was the
biggest mistake in my YouTube career not
posting everything on One Singular
Channel Fouseytube would have over 30
million subscribers if I had done that
because my biggest channel was actually
Dosa fusi where I did daily Vlogs never
on Fouseytube I made a new song called
fusi and I just privated all the videos
so that's why okay well you should you
should put it back up man you guys love
that video huh are you kidding me maple
syrup in the beach we watched the whole
goddamn thing it tastes like beef jerky
keemstar hooked you up with some cheese
and beef jerky brother he got he had you
eating uh maple syrup with a fork did he
oh yeah I don't remember I do that was a
fun trip I remember that trip that was a
fun trip that's good but I was still
drinking at the time so
Fair yeah yeah I'm looking at what else
I uh so
um
so you've been sober for eight months
from everything no no two years oh two
years number 21st September 15th 2021.
you ever feel tempted or you're like
over it not even I was just in Houston I
went bar hopping the whole time live on
stream not even a second that I think oh
my God this would be more fun with a
shot that's not even not even for a
second right
are you a that's that's great but I also
don't do it like also because like I am
I am more religious now oh really
because in this nine months I needed to
hold on to something and I finally found
the relationship that I wanted with God
and so I am religious now so also for my
religion like I just wouldn't do that so
how do you practice your religion today
praying five times a day oh you do the
whole thing yeah
wow that's pretty hardcore isn't it I
missed the morning prayer it's like is
it okay to skip no but I missed out what
do you do if you miss one remake it you
just do it anytime when I wake up hey
actually I was so lost in this podcast I
didn't pray today but I was supposed to
um you wanna you couldn't you want to
make it up right now it's okay okay do
you know where Mecca is which direction
ah there's an app on the phone oh yeah
do you do that Amy I need to learn how
but I do have the app oh you have the
mecca app what's the app called Uh
there's one it's kind of embarrassing
I'm Muslim and that's awesome I just
found my best friend I tell you man he's
gonna become my big guy you teach me to
pray I will
if you need any like if you said what I
want to talk to you about I got stories
for you if you want I got stories
um
let's see the one okay I want to ask you
about the reality show with Bryce Hall
yeah so this one was here let me pull up
that one again that one was really it
seemed like you were being flirtatious
with him good price yeah you really
think you really think I'm like like
that I could be gay it seemed possible
to me uh at the time
I'm actually very comfortable with my
sexuality I see that yeah I believe what
you're saying yeah yeah you've been so
honest with us I believe you would you
would be honest oh my God you know I've
only watched this I think one time and I
could never get myself to watch it again
is it okay if we watch it yeah okay I
was that but it's gonna be a shock to me
right now it was so repulsive let's take
a look money you're drunk right boom I'm
blacked out blacked out save each other
no no you you are
Chicago
right here you can't you can't you can't
put your hands don't do that I'm blacked
out
all right
you don't remember this no way I I
sincerely apologize for being coming
close to your face I thought you didn't
just come close you like face popper
like don't oh thanks Bryce I mean you do
it okay
you said your apology do not touch her
do not say anything just go please thank
you I'm very sorry you're good you're
good you're good you're good kind of
awkward because you all came in here
um to like talk about the night and
fousey just barged in and surprised
that's so capable I'll tell you the
story will really happen right now I do
remember what really happened with me
coming in that room go ahead so so you
do remember
bits and pieces but I remember this
they they I get a text from them cars
coming to pick you up at 10 A.M I get in
the car
it's like it was supposed to be a
two-hour Drive ended up being like a
four hour drive
what do I do in the car I text my then
assistant hey where did you put the
fireball she tells me I get a gallon of
Fireball I start swigging and I tell
them all oh don't worry I'm just getting
a little loose for the show I get to the
show they start doing interviews before
people knew I was there
and every joke I'm saying they're
laughing so I'm thinking oh my God this
is great more alcohol drink drink drink
drink we go in the house
before I threw up and then I go we go in
the house I take massive shots of
tequila blacked out but what I do I do
remember this faintly everybody all the
cast was in the room doing one of those
testimonials in the first day yes I had
just got there well your first hour
they were doing a testimonial right and
they were all talking about me producer
comes up to me hey they need you in that
room you can even rewind this and see me
first walk into this room and see that
they're talking about me I walk in and
I'm like
and I walk up to them and that's when
that incident happened and then Bryce
Hall ended up let me go back and watch
with that context watch rewind rewind
yeah we got multiple colors if you've
been in college if you're trying to go
right after this you can go to college
you're the only drunk person there
because you've been drinking on the way
they were drinking but they had been
there for a full 24 hours some people
had already had sex all right why did
you come late I was a surprise guest oh
I was like what was this show reality
High by Kian and JC
it's like a big brother for YouTube okay
that's interesting
I'm actually so grateful this incident
happened today because this got me sober
oh really
hello
[Applause]
anyways right here they're all talking
about me
by the way this guy's such a piece of
[__] I [__] hate this kid
he lit all his all he literally does is
just straight up steal people
crazy and when people confront him he's
like bro the reason people watch mine is
because I'm just better at it than you I
was like yo it's crazy that people
actually watch this guy he sucks
he is dead
good person had on this
on our personal space and so he is not a
see they told me to go in why are they
talking and I'm drunk if you just got
there no I had I had already like you've
been there for a minute an hour or so
and I showed that I was drunk yeah you
were being a problem already very okay
very obnoxious okay
you could see in my eyes that's not
saying eyes like I was drunk
right
this is our territory we've been here
for how many days feels like two weeks
but it's probably been like two minutes
does not have territory the way that we
do so this is all real right here so the
producers got you in the sense that
they're like yo they you need to go in
there right now because he knew they
were all talking [__] yes because they
all planned them to go in the
testimonial room to talk about how do
you feel about fousey Nikki sneaky
they don't know I'm behind them right
now this is all real they don't know I'm
behind them
Uzi definitely has good intentions I can
tell that he wants to be known in the
influencer world
um
it's the fousey himself
if I don't look it's nothing this is
[__] awkward
I I see where the [__] we stand at
this blue and white boy in this jersey
is gonna protect you from what happens
to you in this house what do you mean
are you good you're such a [__]
master
myself she doesn't need protection
she's a strong woman
we'll watch it oh we're talking about
money okay we're talking about money she
ended up winning the show oh she did
yeah what did she win or anything like I
think a hundred thousand okay
that was super out of hand
were you an aggressive drunk never no no
Angry yeah angry so the story about this
right
and Bryce Hall knocks me out
actually they told me to go into a bed
and sleep
and I would have still been on the show
after this after this yeah I get even
more blocked out I don't remember I
continued drinking no no I was just gone
I get up I go into the bunk bed room and
then here's the other scene so this all
happened at the same time yeah this is
this is within two hours I'll tell you
the host well I'll tell you what
happened after so by the way were you
able to reconcile with her at all never
spoke to her again that's a shame I
think a Mida DM term I'm not sure
I'm pretty sure I would have dm'd her
because there's no way like especially
in sobriety you got to make amends and
there's no way I didn't make amends with
her but I don't remember if she's
watching is there anything you want to
you want to say oh yeah that was
single-handedly the dumbest worst
decision I've ever been in my life I
have never even lifted a finger at a
woman I'm Arab so I have raised the
voice but I've never I would never I
have never I love my mother way too much
I love my sister way too much I love
women way too much
um I'm I was deeply regretful deeply
remorseful there's no justifying that
there's no explaining that nothing
um and yeah I changed my behavior from
that I haven't drank a day since that
because I never want to relive with that
moment
so interesting to see you then and now
because then when you showed up you were
like such a [__] like if I was around
that guy it'd just be like this guy
sucks you would have hated just a
degenerate drunk piece of [__] I've
known people like that though yeah
there's like people with with sub or
specifically alcohol people have known
it's like sober them best friend drunk
them total nightmare yep there's so many
people like that so many people that
once they drink that's actually I don't
want to say his name actually I never
mention his name it's the YouTuber I had
the most beef with that was the thing
with him too him sir no we were when we
were friends he was great when we were
sober and then I went to Brazil with him
ricegum no Vitale I went to Brazil with
him and then I saw him drink for the
first time and I met a completely
different person it's scary it's like
who are arguing the thing that confused
me about I'm one specific friend who's
like my best friend growing up and then
when we went to college you became
alcoholic why is it I'll go why do you
keep drinking like why do you want to be
like that I didn't understand it it's
the same thing as my sex addiction you
don't if you're an alcoholic you're not
con you can't control it yeah it just
takes it's Vitaly huh he's sober now he
says so good for him I mean Vitali is a
[__] psycho I'm not gonna speak on
him that's okay yeah but he I mean he
like beat the [__] out of a random woman
recently you you followed that yeah why
uh
you're do you speak uh okay I'm not I
don't want to embarrass you I'm just
intrigued that your mom's the word on
Vitality I just
that's an energy I don't ever want to
let back into my life around me near me
I see it's just bad news all over it
I've closed the door on that I'm never
going back to that yeah I'd rather not
he still talks about me but I'll never I
understand but you want to know what
happened after this day yeah yeah yeah
yeah so I wake up the next morning on
the couch phone's still in my pocket
maybe we're getting ahead of ourselves
okay I'll watch the next one I'll go go
go okay so this after this they The
Producers tell you go to bed yeah okay
so here's the second one you go to bed
you wake up a couple hours later no no I
don't go to bed I lay in bed yeah I get
up and I go into the room where all the
people are and I start like harassing
everybody okay
okay so let me explain this let me put
context to this for Bryce Hall puts his
cape on and finds his moment to like I'm
Gonna Save the Day because this is after
he got his ass kicked by Austin McBroom
he found his moment so when he pushes me
I think I don't know I'll re-watch her
right now and I tell him
you're lucky I don't tell the world what
I know about you because I know [__]
about Bryce I could have unloaded I
could have unloaded from the beginning
and when I say that
[Music]
he says that's not how it happened but
that's how my drone let's watch it we
can see how it happened exactly
yeah rewind that so you can hear that
rewind that alone
what all this
week
I remember you pushing him no you'll see
actually even when after he pushed me
the first time I walk up to him like
what are you doing bro
isn't it called semantics when it's like
you just have a problem with the way
something was said so I had a problem
with them saying I laid my hands on a
woman because the way I understood that
was I hit a woman I slapped a woman I
think they're right are they yeah if I
did lay my hands on it yeah well that's
what I had a problem with at that time I
didn't I didn't I felt like it was being
unfairly like victimized villainized as
like I feel that that's an accurate
statement okay yeah I mean you didn't
punch her in the face but it was yeah my
fingers no matter what I should never
have ever ever touched her ever yeah in
any capacity but I was an aggressive I
just took when I hear that earphones on
a woman I hear it as light
I think it I think this is covered in my
opinion okay yeah
you're touching his face
yeah so you touch him on the head he
says don't touch me yeah so that's a
provocation yeah
[Music]
he pushed me I walked back I said Bryce
don't push me like that my hands weren't
up my hands weren't up I wasn't ready to
retaliate I wasn't gonna swing back I
wasn't gonna push back I was walking
back blacked out drunk with my hands
down
[Music]
you know what I'm sorry to tell you but
I I don't think he was in the wrong
there okay that's fine like first of all
you have you were already had an acts of
aggression
and you're really getting up in his face
you're unpredictable in the moment
you're already physical with somebody
you know and and the way you're
approaching him
is you know potentially aggressive okay
but you you hold a grudge over that no
no no that punch changed my life saved
my life I'm so grateful for it though I
see Bryce at the gym
that's so good that's the cleanest shot
you could get but when you're blacked
out just like I can come with you
blowing on me you could have blew on me
I would have fell over when you're
blacked out drunk I'm getting the sense
that your ego was a little bit bruised
by how you got knocked out there no not
at all not at all I'm grateful for that
moment I literally have thanked God for
that moment if that moment is gonna
downplay the quality of that knockout
though no that was a group that you know
how clean that hit was that was a clean
clean and plus so much respect for Bryce
he's about to do a bare knuckle boxing
match he's like really yeah that's the
first YouTuber to have balls to do this
on the show recently I liked them yeah
so I have nothing uh and Bryce knows
this that's good
that's good
um
that must not hurt like a [__] didn't
feel it didn't no it's not you were just
lights out oh this happens I wake up you
could play it if you want to continue
playing see what happens
I'll tell you something else that I got
mad that he did though
damn that that was that was brutal so he
took a picture of me knocked out yeah
and sent it he was on FaceTime with
Josie Canseco and he sent it to her
laughing like look what I just did and I
didn't appreciate that sure that's a
look that's a little uh so the next
morning I wake up from on the couch
phone's still in my Pocket clothes still
on
confused as [__] don't even remember
getting to the house yeah walk up to a
producer yo what's going on where's my
bed uh you said if you were in a
physical altercation last night we're
sending you home oh [__] what the [__]
are you talking about physical education
with who your face hurt so much and the
back of my head from hitting the ground
right with who Bryce Hall
what Bryce that's my homie it's all good
we were drunk let me talk to him we're
good no we cannot let you see each other
your Uber's outside sent me home I go
home sleep that whole day off and I knew
I just put my hands on a woman like you
the where did you know
um no because they told me what happened
oh they told you yeah yeah yeah so I go
home so I call my event manager at the
time keemstar's manager
what do they manage his [__] beef
jerky flavor
I
say John I [__] up I [__] up bad so
I tell him downstairs no oh what
happened to that guy he's still doing
videos no way I think
so then
um
he goes I know a guy who can fix this
when I hear that I'm like oh I know a
guy like he's gonna get me out of this
yeah he calls a guy
the guy and then a couple of they tell
me we're sending a therapist to your
house she's gonna talk to you tell her
everything about your life and then
we're gonna think of a plan tomorrow she
comes over like a damage control
situation that's what I thought okay
so she comes over she tells me
everything I tell her everything was
this live no oh you said you knew it was
kind of I knew it was coming yeah so my
my mind think about where I was so the
next day I wake up I was and I called
John right when I wake up John what
happened we were supposed to have a call
Yusuf we had a call
pack your bags you're going to rehab in
Pennsylvania now at the time I thought
oh going to rehab I'm just doing this
for damage control right the guy John
reached out to I don't know if I'm
allowed to say his name publicly because
he's like a savior for everybody in the
industry not just YouTube when Astro
world happened they called this guy the
AstroWorld incident this is the guy like
the guy and he's been sober for so many
years and he believes in sobriety when
John called him and this was made me
respect John so much as a manager John
didn't tell him my client put his hands
on a girl get him out of the situation
John called him and said yo I've been
managing Yusuf for X long every time
we've drank he's gotten into problems we
were just at the Jake Paul fight a
couple of weeks ago and five feet away
from Dave Chappelle he almost fought a
fan for like messing with him I always
got in trouble when I drank so Jed the
guy
said
I'm gonna get him sober but he has to
want to help himself to get helped
I go to rehab I turn my phone in
not even know what to expect the best 30
days I could have ever experienced in my
entire life that's really nice that your
manager actually yeah was looking out
for your welfare in that moment yeah
like he doesn't manage me anymore but
has nothing to do with that that
actually means he was there in a big way
and so how long
um from this happening
to it being aired two months two months
yeah and so did you know it was coming
when it was when it was uploaded I did
but at the time I was so like grounded
in my sobriety the analogy I said in
rehab on day 30 when I was leaving so I
was saying my goodbye
the way I see it is I'm standing in the
middle and there's a fire around me
meaning the comments that are coming in
but I don't have to feel the burn
meaning I don't now that I've come to
terms with that incident now that I
admit that I was an alcoholic it needed
to be helped nothing anybody can say
about that moment can hurt me is that
yeah that got me through because I'm
sure a lot of people are a lot to say
after seeing that yeah and it got me
through it because I was sober I was
going to meetings I was working out
that's what got me on my workout grind
working out every day I was bettering
myself eating healthier I quit vaping I
quit massage parlors I quit alcohol I
quit weed I was finally finally once
walking the walk and talking the talk
and did you ever make a statement or
anything about it very brief posted on
my Instagram story yeah and I just said
guys there's nobody who could be more
remorseful from this incident than hi
I'm sorry to everybody involved I
apologize I should have never I've I've
taken actions that I needed to do to get
better and yeah I moved on
that's yeah that's a that was a horrible
situation yeah
but in the career of fousey it's like
what do you expect you know every year
there has to be something right that was
it for that year because my year was
going good I was doing the boxing stuff
I had just got into Tesla after having
the down grow downgrade to a Toyota CHR
after July 15. like I was finally on my
way up again this happened on my way
down but then rehab
I became a machine so then how long ago
was that that this 2021 the rehab 2021
and so it's been like what three years
have you been kind of good since then
with with all the with all your
addictions now I'm not perfect but with
with alcohol especially yes I haven't
drank in a single sip since
um
I forgot what I was gonna say right now
but oh yeah so when I got into that
amazing sober shape perfect shape I
finally got to a point where I was like
I want the world to see this new me like
the eagle wanted its validation again
get a call you want to fight deji oh
yeah here's my chance because veggie was
the guy that lost all of his fights yeah
you'd probably be like Elena I had just
watched Alex Wasabi beat him
deji comes up to me right after the Alex
Wassabi fight in the hotel lobby he
looks at me would you fight me yeah I
would
it was set on from there and that was it
good I should never have done the thing
is he's one of the best experience for
boxers he is one of the best influencer
boxers technically yeah I should never
have gotten that ring I knew I was going
to lose two weeks before the fight
bawling my eyes out in nervous hysterics
every day right I had a tear I still
have a tfcc tear right here from it I
was nervous I knew I was gonna lose my
brother was begging me my oldest one
used to pull out because the last boxing
match was such a disaster such a
disaster my brother was begging me pull
out Yusuf and I said no Alex Wasabi just
pulled out against KSI if I pull out two
it's gonna look so bad I have to do it I
have to do it I should have pulled out
I'm not a boxer Did you get paid for
that was it was it was it yeah worth it
for you and that's it well it ended up I
ended up losing at all of it because
going to rehab I went to two mental
institutions in the last nine months the
first one was just the 10-day one and
that one was like twenty five thousand
dollars oh wow and then the one I did
um which was a 30 day one
was it a 30 day or 17 something like
that more recently was I forgot but
upwards of there and then ending up
having a money here money here money
here it was all gone by the end of it
again I always wondered
um
you rented out the Greek for this big
show how much did that cost you so
here's the thing with that I paid out of
pocket everything I think the Greek
Theater alone was like 300 000 something
yeah but then also paid all the artists
first class flights to the LA and their
Entourage and their bottle service for
the hotels everything craziest thing
about it event gets canceled due to a
bomb threat yeah you would think
Ticketmaster and Live Nation would say
yo we got canceled doodle bomb threat
wasn't your doing let us give you
another date
but I was with a very very very very
very shady guy at the time actually he
burned Roman Atwood he was Roman
Atwood's ex manager
I think that they gave him back a
percentage of it or a portion of it and
he just left and never said so how much
money were you out on that after all
July 15th I lost
well over a million wow yeah so that's
how you kind of burned your your save
how was the first first big hit yeah and
then after that obviously my career is
Flatline and nothing came of that really
it was just a total disaster publicity
yeah so then that's a hoverboard
flatlined after that yeah so at that
point it's like what are you to do
that's tough yeah do you have any idea
about who made the threat or what was
the threat I think I know
um again in order to get past something
in life you have to take accountability
and take ownership for it all so I blame
nobody but myself
but if I were to be detective for a
second
two hours before the event I'm still in
the hotel waiting I get a call I got a
DM from Sam Pepper
Sam Pepper and pepper and he says yo
foosi everybody was talking about the
event yo fusi can I come to your event
of course brother because we were
beefing of course brother this event is
called hate dies love arrives I'd love
to have you Sam Pepper's live streaming
put two and two together how do you
think maybe it was one of his audience
100 I think so I could be you I could be
horribly wrong he was just like if it's
that easy to clear a whole [__] venue
wouldn't it happen every day
be some little [__] that called
unless unless unless some hierarchy
Illuminati person was like we're not
gonna let this event happen he's pal I
don't know there could be so many
conspirations you believe that what's
crazy is you believe that's possible oh
yeah why would so why why would there be
uh someone that wouldn't want you to
have the event I don't know I'm just
these are all just I'm not I'm not
saying these I don't want people to take
unpack it I'm curious where your mind's
at it could it could just be you know
Palestinian Muslim has this much energy
and control and eyes on him like that's
not good surely there's other
bro in this industry if it wasn't for
Rami and Mohammed recently we have
nobody
we have nobody what the [__] being
Muslim in Hollywood you know how scared
I was to be a Muslim in Hollywood um
that seems far-fetched to me
I promised you it's closer than you
think our representation from the show
rameen Mohammed is new
very new
so
but yeah the thing I was always confused
about was like
was it credible do you know what they
said who they talked to I know I was in
the Uber I'm on my way to the event
I get a call from my then ex-girlfriend
she's crying right when I answer baby
what's wrong
somebody called in a bomb threat the
event is canceled that's all I ever
heard of it that's all I ever got never
spoke to a police never spoke to anybody
nothing those three those that sentence
right there was the death of my life
that caused everything that's crazy yeah
and you didn't charge for tickets right
they were free give it free nobody got
hurt by this event but me yeah
nobody bought a single ticket I didn't
scam I didn't do nothing I gave out five
thousand free tickets there were 75 000
people watching on the live stream
before it even started DJ Khaled is
Palestinian I think yeah he does massive
shows all the time
yeah but Hassan Minaj
true yeah but all this representation
all this representation representation
is new
um
DJ Khaled no but DJ Khaled like he lives
like he would think he's American he
drinks he parties he does all this stuff
right they're not like about I mean
they're not like out there like but you
weren't devout either no I wasn't so why
would someone want to bomb I'm not that
wasn't it I'm not I'm just testing that
there I am not riding by that theory
yeah I'm just throwing [__] out I think
it was a Sam Pepper thing that's that
sounds more likely he's live streaming
at the time where ice Poseidon is
getting dog talk about another piece of
[__] didn't that guy was didn't he like
run from the authorities back to England
because after some massive scam the coin
with people from FaZe what a [__]
that guy's a real piece of work man oh
yeah and he was also alleged
he was he's an alleged uh r wordist as
well I believe is that really is that
right Olivia I don't know that
that's where the pepper comes in I don't
play by that well what was it that was
alleged about Sam
oh yes Save the kids coin that was
iconic
they made save the kids coin and yeah
again bring it back to me getting
canceled for fake pranks I know some of
these people's favorite YouTubers
scammed the [__] out of them with a [__]
coin and they're acting like Logan
Paul's still doing that he literally
scammed them like two times in the past
year
and people still watch him I think Logan
is gonna make good with it though I
truly do I know it didn't happen on the
timeline everybody wanted it to but I
think he's gonna make good with it
you're cool by the way I don't even know
how much time has passed but this has
been so much this has been such an
effortless and nice conversation I
appreciate you for having me thank you I
really appreciate you being so honest I
think it's special it's nice to sit
across from someone who's so open with
their with everything they've been
through in life yeah
well you're wearing a black shirt so it
doesn't really show or a brand new shirt
for you
I like that shirt thank you so anyway
did we finish watching this clip yeah
yeah basically I get knocked out and
then I forgot what the 2014 a fan
uploaded a video accusing Sam of R
wording her and a few more girls came
out as well damn that guy sucks
this guy stinks he sure does and that's
putting it mild dude
[Music]
I feel bad he DM me recently telling me
to move to kick dumbass can I talk about
the subathon sure
um 19 days ago yeah
I was going to the gym going to school
for personal training contemplating Uber
contemplating working at Starbucks I
actually would have started Uber but by
chance my license was suspended so I
didn't get access to the app or like
months later
um but I do signed up on my Uber driver
now like through the app I can start
driving right now if I wanted but I do a
live stream
and that night I'm like you know what
guys I'm not gonna cut off the cameras
I'm just gonna keep the cameras running
while I sleep one day turned into two
two days turned into three and now it's
day 19 I've been live for 24 hours a day
seven days a week whether I'm [__]
eating sleeping on a date in Houston
wherever I'm live and I have I'm
starting to curate the most supportive
audience I've had a lot of supportive
audiences because the two streamings I
won that was fan voted so my dose of
fousey's family voted for me to do that
this G7 family shits on them
shits on them [__] those fans [__] those
fans it's all about G7 baby geez you
want to know what G7 seven I think AB
tried to explain it to me it's like uh
game seven
it's game seven in the NBA Finals yeah
there's point four seconds left on the
clock okay the coach draws up a play and
says Ethan the ball's coming to you what
do you do in that moment do you flop and
fold or do you make the shot or dunk and
win for your team and have your whole
city go crazy if you make the shot you
got G7 in you it's like G7 mentality I
see and that's just that's right is that
your original did you coin that phrase
or did it exist before I coined it G7
baby game seven and what's so crazy I
was recently doing an IRL swear to God
hands in the air there's clips of it
online I was doing an IRL in Walmart
when I get home and I'm checking my
Discord reactions for that day they go
look what aisle you were on swear to God
Jesus you know it was swear to God
alhamdulillah G7 no but they're so
supportive and I plan to do it for the
whole year good for you yeah I think
it's cool I told my mom people are into
it yeah when my mom asked me to stop I
said Mama why she want you to stop she
thinks it's like she thinks I'm
exhausting myself and it's too tiring
for me she's a mom you know probably
right I lost my voice two weeks ago
still hasn't come back yeah I said Mama
motion like this on Twitch does not come
this is like once in a lifetime if I
were to stop right now I'm the dumbest
idiot in the world right I'm gonna
sacrifice right now success requires
sacrifice I'm gonna sacrifice if it
lasts a year it lasts two years because
I know it's gonna be worth it in the end
that's good so I'm every weekend I'm
traveling to a different city this
weekend I'm going to Nashville for
misfits08 so I'll be the only live
streamer with behind the scenes access
to everything hopping behind the scenes
the weekend after I'm going to I think
I'm going to Miami for Aiden Ross the
weekend after I'm going to uh Ross doing
so me and I sat on string Aiden reacted
to a clip of mine I reacted back and
said Aiden I want to train you in the
gym because he's DM me before and said
yo can you get me right when I release
my fitness app I said I got you brother
so I responded back and said Aiden I
want to train you he responded yesterday
and said come to Miami so I'm gonna ask
him to go to my city next weekend to
bring you on yeah I mean he's huge right
and then I'm going to do Toronto with a
bunch of viewers there's four viewers
and I know them by name Chronos we call
them chromosome that's his name yeah his
name is Bobby okay he's India his name
is Bobby yeah Adele Adele the pilot
chromosome like yeah like are you you're
not like not chromosome defect like
normal nice amount of chromosomes no
defect oh he has the chromosome defense
yes
[Music]
Skittles and they they all told me they
were going to Toronto and I literally
said can I go with you guys I don't do
boys trips ever can I go and they said
yes so I'm literally going with it I
like that yeah good for you especially
if you're doing all this sober that's
awesome yeah
saying on your meds and they're all
younger than me they're like 24 25 so I
see them as like they see me as like a
mentor
yeah I mean I think it's great that
you're
keeping all your mental health in mind
staying on your meds because I don't
think anybody wants to nobody wants to
see that nobody everybody's rooting for
you think about me I don't want to see
that just be careful just because it
happens every year doesn't mean I
purposely wanna work like I want to
self-sabotage myself now yeah almost did
going to the airport with mine you did
bro you were close I was [__]
people people love that stream though
yeah yeah Aidan Ross's band from twitch
what is he's on kick now he's on Kik oh
you can't stream with him no so I think
for that says I think for that seven
hours that I stream yeah I'm gonna put
mine on a clip channel so they can watch
clips and go stream on Kik and then come
back I'm not doing it for the
subscribers I'm doing it just uh which
rule is that you can't stream with him
on Twitch but you can stream with them
somewhere else I'm not a hundred percent
certain but I'm praying you know the
rules right
I'm not actually sure of that combo but
but it seems to be trouble it seems
unlikely that twitch is like you cannot
collab with him anywhere I mean that
seems a little bit crazy the pay
discrepancy between twitch and Kik is
absolutely insane yeah but kick is gonna
kick is funded by like dark money you
think so oh for sure it's literally
funded by a crypto gambling casino and I
mean it's literally just a front but
don't they have it because
don't they have it don't they have the
money because of steak oh they have the
money yeah oh they've got a lot they
have unlimited money I mean steak
or a kick as a website is literally just
a front for circumventing twitch's
gambling rules that's literally the only
reason it exists I see that
um I definitely see that the one reason
like if I were to ever get a kick deal
and they ever said you need to promote
gambling I'd have to turn it down
because religiously I can't promote
gambling yeah I wouldn't say no you know
get get paid or get paid but I know dude
those guys are
those guys are scum we'll see if a deal
comes in are you even talked I DM dating
he said let me look at myself yeah nice
70 30 split
I don't know oh wait twitch takes 50
wait twitch went back to 70. they're
yeah they're introducing a new program
that's coming in a few months at 70 30.
oh well right now they take 50. that's
how it's always been and then at a
certain level you go up to set 70 30
right
yeah I don't know what's the deal with
twitch they really [__] I do 70 30. I
told them I'm not like I I didn't
YouTube 70 30 from the beginning yeah I
I didn't start this for the money so
even like people always say go to kick
go to kick you would make 50 more but
I'm like if I'm successful on Twitch and
I lose 50 but I could go to kick and not
be successful and get 95. I'm saying
stay on the pledge that's where the
people are I'm staying on Twitch Kyson
Nat is on Twitch and that's the biggest
streamer in the world if he can do it so
can I everybody's on Twitch kick is a
[__] I don't think Kick's Gonna Last
I'm gonna collab with Kai this year
tour he's been a fan for years so what's
your pitch if he's watching him
Tyson that I got motion right now dog
you taught me about that I got motion
right now I got motion right now on
Twitch I want that collab with you you
watched me growing up and I you said I
me and Roman inspired you now I'm asking
you I want to collab with you dog heart
to heart I want to collab with you what
do you want to do let's paint it let's
paint a picture let's get let's get this
going so with desktop streams you don't
plan the content you just sit there and
do whatever it happens I just want to be
on the same camera I want to be sitting
next to Kai with the camera in front of
me that's what I want there it is
you owe him I actually got asked John
the keemstar manager called me this is
right before I went to the first mental
health and no the second Mental Health
institution this year Kai did a 30-day
sabathon and John goes yo Kai's doing
sabathon we're planning out the
activities would you and Roman like to
show up and surprise him
I was going into a Mental Health
institution so I said I can't um
it's okay you get through it's time when
you're ready yeah all right Kai you owe
foosi for all he's done for you
a lot of people man have been inspired
by fousey you know the I love when we're
creators can admit that like Bradley
Martin for example I found Bradley
Martin when he was a security guard at a
Chris Brown charity football game I made
his YouTube I pushed all my all right
yes I pushed on my dose of [__]
followers to him but the reason I
respect Bradley so much there is never
an interview where my name gets brought
up or he doesn't say I thank you sir for
getting me started you know what Bradley
he's been on the show too he's a total
sweetheart
such a [__] Meathead though but I
love him I do love him as a person
ugh and those milk boys don't even get
me started but hey we're all here
you don't got to get involved in my beef
you got a lot of beef with them
uh nah I like Bradley though he's a good
guy well that's it I mean listen we've
been going for two hours can I talk
about one more thing before we go yeah I
was I was just going to ask one final
story I'd like to share with you and the
audience would like yeah so during this
nine months
when I I so I had just gotten out of the
Mental Health institution
didn't work I was stuck I was paralyzed
I was like literally calling mental to
get admitted I was calling and saying I
can't handle reality anymore I can't
handle time like it was a weird the
weirdest thing in the world I didn't
know how to handle time just sitting
here was like even when you call an Uber
and it says five minutes I didn't know
what to do in those five minutes like it
was weird I was detached there's a lot
of people that say it's dark night of
the soul and all these other things but
it was deep so my impulsive ask it's a
bright idea I hear about Ayahuasca
Ayahuasca will give you the answers
Ayahuasca will show you which way to go
in life so what do I do
I had cash left over from selling my
treadmill I sold my treadmill because I
was going to sell everything this year
and go become a monk I was going to live
as a in a monastery for the rest of my
life so I sold my treadmill I had cash I
booked a flight to Peru I go to Peru for
a
I forgot how long
Ayahuasca journey I end up in the middle
of the Jungle no Wi-fi mosquitoes and
bugs and spiders everywhere like just
middle of the Jungle by myself
I'm not on my sleeping pill so I went
nine days there without sleeping while
you cannot sleep without the pill I
cannot sleep nine days imagine sitting
in the jungle listening to the Jungle
sounds from Midnight until 9am when it's
time to wake up or you're conscious the
entire time not only make you go crazy
now imagine doing Ayahuasca every other
day
that was the darkest whole trip I have
ever had in my life so I I understand
about the Ayahuasca uh journey is that
you puke and [__] and stuff did that
happen yeah bro bro you don't only puke
when I puked it felt like a devil was
coming out of me I felt like I was
purging all the toxic [__] but my
Visions were so dark here I am thinking
I'm gonna do Ayahuasca it's gonna tell
me I need to be a civil engineer and I
need to start a family
I experienced the real life exorcism in
my vision I experienced
um I was in the middle of like the the
desert and there was a father who had a
mental disability holding his son crying
so I was feeling pain did your father
have a mental disability my father goes
through depression yeah do you feel like
that was in a 100 allegory for you and
your dad I don't know if that Vision was
enough yeah but that's deep or maybe it
was you were holding a part of yourself
that's deep but the craziest Vision I
had and this taught me real fear you
know the movie get out yeah remember the
sunken place my mind went there and I
couldn't get out during the visit
couldn't get sober or oh you were stuck
in the I was stuck in the sunken Place
lost control of my mind and I saw how
far your mind can actually go and I
thought about you know when people go
crazy and they're officially like in a
room with Dwight wearing a white thing I
understood why people get there because
where your mind can go is [__]
terrifying and I went there and I
couldn't get out and it was the
single-handedly the scariest experience
of my life I was supposed to do eight
Ayahuasca sessions I did four one night
when when it wore off I'm in the middle
of the Cabana like The Bungalow I'm
texting my sister and that guy I talked
about who's a savior and my therapist at
the time I'm not making sense help me I
need to leave
I haven't slept for nine days in Peru
get me home but it's all misspelled not
making sense got on a flight went to my
sisters in Philadelphia started my real
Rehabilitation and that's where I am wow
craziest night Monday first time you did
Ayahuasca were that were they worried
about you during that time who the
Ayahuasca people didn't no the
journeyman or whatever no they didn't
even know no because I thought the whole
point was that they're supposed to like
guide you
they do they have shamans there but the
shamans are like playing music and
singing These Angelic chords to you you
wouldn't believe the sounds coming out
of these people's mouths it's in a
different language but it's scary like
when I said I was leaving on day four
and not day eight they said we have to
we have to like you can't just leave
that's dangerous right they had to like
he had to drink something spit on my
head tap my head rub it on me do a
prayer because I was bathing in Plants
every day it's called plant medicine it
would give me this plant and they gave
me the strongest one because of how
severe I told them my story was and I
had to shower in it like I was do like
it felt like I was doing some dark scary
[__] it wasn't just the LA Ayahuasca
where it's like let's all get together
and do some Ayah this is real Peruvian
Ayahuasca in the jungle with real life
shamans this [__] was dark so the first
time you did it was it immediately bad
horrible and then why'd you do it a
second time because I got told it would
get better I got told by the guy by next
Wednesday you're gonna start feeling
better you have to rid yourself of all
the toxic in your life and all the toxic
you've acquired over the years to be
able to accept the good um
he had been there for a year you know
what he told me when he wasn't working
and I was finally ready to go home he
said Yusuf I think you should stay here
for six months to a year you really need
it
you feel like they're scammers no it
helped everybody else that was there
everybody else left with the biggest
Smiles I loved lying that was wrong
advice for you
I didn't I didn't even research it I
didn't know what Ayahuasca was
psychedelics or dangerous man if you're
not mentally in the right place it
doesn't matter if it's Ayahuasca acid
mushrooms and one night my ass so
addicts always want more one is not
enough yeah so one night knowing how bad
it was this was day three I took three
shots of Ayahuasca oh you went hard on
some girls there take half of one I took
three full
and what was your logic there of going
so hard on it maybe I'll get to where
everybody else is getting to get more
[__] up yeah
that's an addict's mind more more more
right never just one it's never just one
and you remember any of the other
Visions you had other than like the dad
holding the the dad holding I remember
that one
um
oh I do remember another one but it was
a weird one
um The Exorcism that one was terrible
what was that like I'm in a house in the
middle of nowhere and I'm really
watching a girl like
you're you're watching someone else get
exercise yes I get exercise yeah but I'm
I'm there I'm scared like I feel it I
feel Darkness I feel it but the craziest
Vision I had it was weird and I was like
is this my answer and it was this
constant voice in my head I saw my
parents a lot and it was like the answer
to life is move in with your parents
take care of your mom and dad worship
the ground your mom walks on do
everything she needs you to do get
married get a a regular respectable job
whether that be Uber Costco wherever and
just live a normal life pray to God five
times a day this life is short the next
life is forever that's not crazy but but
it just it was so it's just it's not
crazy but it was just so just like and I
asked myself like is that the answer but
the sucky thing about Aya like any other
psychedelic while you're under you feel
it and it's like yes once it wears off
you think that's gonna stay with you
you're back the regular [__]
I didn't that that experience didn't
stick that one didn't but that's also
but like the relationship with my mom it
did I treat my mom like the queen she
deserves to be she's the love of my life
I love her I call her almost every day
my father not so much we don't have a
good relationship but that's because
he's just he's TR he doesn't know how to
be a father by an American term as a
father your mom and dad live together
yeah and so that's interesting that
there's a rift between
you and your father but while you and
your mom are so close yeah and my my
mom's religious my dad isn't oh
interesting yeah he's like totally
reformed like like atheist
I would I wouldn't want to say that I
would feel so sad to say that's my
father but
um I hope he I hope he turns to Allah
why is it that him being an atheist
would make you sad
um as a Muslim it's just that's like
that's just you can't that's the worst
that's the worst yeah to deny God when
it's it's the worst you can do
but is that how you feel about atheists
in general I personally have nothing
like I have always I don't ask people
about their religion they call it like
their nationality well language I don't
give a [__] yeah I meet the person do I
like that person cool you could be an
atheist and I don't want to say this and
like I said the I am gay lion and
getting misconstrued but also in the
same veid you can be non-binary you
could be gay you could be whatever I
don't it's just that he's your dad he's
my father yeah and you want the best for
your father and my religious belief
system says that if he dies not
admitting that there is one true God and
Muhammad is his Prophet it's not going
to be good for my father in the
afterlife and you believe that you're
like I do yeah you're in I do it's
interesting I I was so by the way
this is the first time in my life I have
ever said something like that so
publicly I used to be scared of My
Religion like the fact that I'm Muslim
and feeling like people wouldn't accept
me it's very intense it's pretty intense
statement yeah but I try to like I pray
on stream because it's 24 7. I tell them
I go guys I'm Live 24 7. I have to pray
in my life I'm not trying to sway you
convince or not one of those people yeah
I'm not like I almost said George Janko
going around telling everybody why Jesus
is King no disrespect but I don't try to
put my beliefs onto anybody I don't know
enough about the religion I think it's
cool I think representation of like you
know
uh regular people who are who are Muslim
I think is good for people to see you
know yes and and for the first time in
my life because my entire life of being
Muslim is such a farce such a farce you
didn't believe it no I was like we
didn't think I almost said another
YouTuber's name who's a hundred times
worse than me Muslim on camera but you
should see him off camera
and I I was tired of doing that and now
like alhamdulillah I I do pray
alhamdulillah
Adam Saleh
huh
you never asked me huh this whole time
you hear it every word I said
um
um if you had a best friend who was an
atheist would you worry about them
or do you kind of just like what's your
focus I'm curious
if I was his best friend like already
yeah why am I gonna care
if you were his best friend already why
would you like if if I was his best
friend that means I like him as a person
yeah I like his morals I like his values
I like who you believe that like
I do believe that like a Christian a Jew
and a Muslim can all be right in their
beliefs or is it just Islam's the only
way no they are right in their beliefs
and that's a question that I asked my
mom when I was younger when I was trying
to understand religion because of how it
was introduced to me I said Mama just
like you're telling me you're right the
Christian mom is telling the Christian
kid that he's right the Jewish mom is
telling the Jewish kid that he's right
the Buddhist mom is sung the Buddha say
he's right how do we know who's right
she said that's where faith comes in
so I don't I don't mind they can all be
right in whatever I have my own beliefs
that's that's to nobody else nobody has
to believe me agree with me anything
that would be disrespectful of me to be
like you're wrong there are people who
do do that but they're knowledgeable
they know about [__] I'm not
knowledgeable enough about Islam
I'm not okay but I just I'm the only
when I told my brother that when I was
telling him because I was having a
really hard time finding religion and my
oldest brother is very religious and I
told him that he said Yusuf don't over
complicate it all Islam asked for you
believe that there is one true God
Muhammad is his prophet and you pray
five times a day nice start from there
that's it work your way out that's it
good I'm glad thanks for giving me the
platform to say that thanks for coming
on but of course I think like I said I
think it's good the representation of
like it's good I mean
the the mus the Islam as a religion is
just so [__] uh
so I mean
it's since 9 11 it's just been so
ruthless for it is but I also think it's
been so misunderstood since nine totally
100 I think is that that's what I was
getting at just totally misunderstood
there's so many normal great I mean
they're all normal great people that's
the thing yeah you know and there's just
like us and also also to be fair there's
extremists in every religion oh for sure
I mean look at I always say look at the
the settlers in Israel there's psychotic
[__] genocidal freaks you know
I'm not really Jewish religiously it's
more of a close I'm not religious I'm
more atheist agnostic than anything but
but yeah I still love you I still
respect you see that doesn't like you
telling me that right now if you're
wondering does it change anything within
me not at all
nice not at all
oh CR wait keemstar reacted to the live
already [__] me oh here it is
oh he's pissed
that's not him that's old
I think that's in library
these pissed that you're here dude
wow
[Music]
sorry Kim I'm sorry Keem he's super
angry I'm sorry Keem
get it out kid I'm sorry Keem get it out
brother I'll get you beef jerky and
maple syrup I'll make up for it
am I allowed to shamelessly plug before
I leave please do plug
twitch.tv backslash fousey is Live 24 7.
no matter what time you go on it I will
be live you will be watching me I have a
girl coming over tonight a girl guest I
met at the gym bro no no well she comes
I I do like
I try to like raise her up a little
that's what they're saying the cool kids
use Riz I try to do that a little I'm
kind of like a The Wizard of Oz how long
you last with there huh how long would
you last with there in bed yeah five
seconds five seconds yeah no shot no
shot it's been a year no shot no shot
um and also I have a fitness app
www.fitbyfussy.com it has meal plans
workout programs follow along videos
where you can watch and work out I like
I said I wouldn't have got out of
depression if it wasn't for the gym and
a lot of people don't understand the gym
so if you need a little help
fitbyfussy.com and you can get literally
into the best shape of your life there
are proven testimonials right now people
have done it good I may have seen you
you definitely have been insanely and
thank you so so so much for letting me
plug that thank you of course thank you
for coming on you know it's really nice
to have you on it's it's nice to learn
you've been through so much stuff I
think a lot of people have a lot to
learn and and from the things you've
been through you know and shout out to
my G7 effing Army we're doing it we up
we got motion we ain't stopping G7 to
the Moon we're gonna become the number
one IRL most Subs twitch streamer in the
world Insha'Allah and do you want to
shout out the massage parlor nah no if
you want to know I could tell I could
like say hello Paige no I don't want to
go there actually do they have like do
they have Google reviews I'm sorry I'm
sorry don't don't worry do they have
like Google reviews like do they have a
radio horrible they're horrible oh
they're horrible but they're horrible
but here's why so I'll have like two
stars but if you read the reviews it'll
be like a girl writing saying this was
the weirdest worst massage ever she's
giving me the shittiest massage ever she
demanded a tip afterwards because if you
go in and you're not getting a happy
ending they hate yourself if you're just
there for a normal massage so mad
so mad they say like I got my dick
slapped not knowing why slapped your
[__] bro yeah
this woman sexually assaulted me slapped
my dick around
love that and I went back for more every
single week thank you for coming on and
being so honest it's been uh it's been
great no Trump Loves You by the way I
haven't looked at chat and I was
terrified too but truly no it's good
truly truly truly Ethan it's nice to
hear from you I know this sounds like a
lot of glazing but truly Ethan where I
was this last nine months the fact that
I'm sitting on your podcast right now
and I got to tell my story like I know I
say it a lot but it's the same way I I
thank them every single day for their
support on Twitch because I'm for the
first time in my life I'm actually
grateful I have gratitude the first time
I had success I wasn't grateful I
actually tweeted out when I was
successful back then on YouTube and I
said why the [__] am I making 300 000 a
year doctors and school teachers should
be paid more than me so I was telling
God in the universe I don't want this
money because I could have done good
with that money I could have retired so
many people in my family I could have
helped the needy for days I wasn't
grateful this time I thank them every
single day like eight times a day I go
on full-blown rants thanking them for
how much they changed my life so in that
same vein thank you for putting me on
here and literally this is probably the
biggest thing that's gonna happen to me
all year do you have methods of keeping
yourself grounded through all this you
know gym the gym prayer yeah prayer
because that's going to be important I
think well we're so the one big shift
we're doing I've been streaming to like
8 A.M we play fortnite at night so I
stream till 8 A.M and then wake up at
like 2 4. last night we slept at 6 p.m
woke up at 4am went to the gym by 6am
went home showered took my dog out and
now I'm here so we made a rule we're
gonna start sleeping early and waking up
early there you go yeah
they're helping me they help me like
hear this [__] there's one other
question I wanted to ask is all coming
to me how much money would you say you
made
over your career up until like you lost
it all at the Greek I don't know the
exact number but I'd say like over the
years like with all the spending because
I was spending so much like my monthly
charges on my AmEx were like 30 40 000 a
month on a low day on a low month
um well over 7 million I think so and so
you made over 7 million and what were
you spending it all on
massage parlors but that wasn't the big
Crux of it I bought two Ferraris about a
Range Rover svr I bought Rolexes my
teeth my teeth cost a hundred thousand
dollars now wow
um grills
um designer like I would go to Louis
Gucci Everything thinking that material
[__] meant to [__] this is fake as [__]
so if you guys are thinking this saying
he's talking about humility and he's
wearing a chain I was just in Houston
live on stream went to a diamond Checker
and he said it's fake as [__] this and
this they're not really buy them ticket
they were real no no no no I know
they're fake now but but now material
[__] doesn't mean jack [__] to me
I understand like how [__] minuscule
they are cars and material things stupid
it's so stupid I I was trying to fill a
void thinking that buying more again an
addict more Was Gonna Fill the whole
more no it's not
never going to do that there it is guys
Fouseytube he's on Twitch
I'll even go this far if you guys watch
this show and you don't use twitch much
you can sub to foosi for free if you
have Amazon Prime thank you so much
you know what I mean it's easy we got 20
000 subscribers in 19 days to the point
you got people like Ethan at first
saying it's fake people tweet me every
day there's no way a person who averages
two thousand to four thousand viewers
has 19 000 subscribers when your rage
and Phantom and agent have 24 000
viewers but you have more than them
but dang G7 I'm just kidding I love you
agent I Love You Phantom I love you
um your age but the one thing so you can
go to a website and see how much are
gifted like I something like 90 are
getting gifted yeah that's why I'm so
scared does that make you nervous
because like after a month maybe they
all go there but even I mean what's 90
of 20 000 it's still a decent chunk
regardless
so what I'm doing I'm preparing myself
for that already I'm not setting
expectations that this is forever I will
still be so grateful for what they did
get me to and I'm sure like regardless
if I had 3 000 subscribers a month that
all I want people ask me like do you
want money again do you want this I
don't want super cars I don't want
jewelry I don't want clothes but I want
enough money to be able to go because in
my culture you have to speak to the
girl's father I want enough money to be
able to go up to a girl's father and say
I want your daughter's hand in marriage
and when he asks me can you financially
support her say yes did Lena's dad ask
you that baby
it's sort of he's a man of few words but
uh we did have to talk to a chef and
give a monetary value if we were to get
divorced oh dude I had to do that too
with the rabbinite in Israel because me
and Neila got married and I thought that
was so weird we had a marriage contract
and there was like
if you guys get married or divorced you
have to pay her such and such amount of
money so you guys do that [__] too huh
yeah yeah all I want now is to be able
to get married what if you're broke or I
mean what if you're just like a normal
dude who works at a restaurant I was
broke as [__] I had like 50 bucks in the
bank so so I don't understand money I'm
not financially literate so I asked I
would ask my brother and sister when I
was about to work at Starbucks how is
working at Starbucks going to fund my
lifestyle it's impossible obviously you
have to change some things around I
can't be driving a Tesla I just got a
brand new Tesla so you gotta when did
you get the Tesla two days ago but now
why I got it yeah I bought I at least a
Tesla Model y two years ago with the
intention I'm still gonna be doing good
in my career when this lease is overall
by the Cyber truck cyber truck never
came in so I said okay I'll buy out this
model why it's perfect cheap payments
everything's good Tesla has a rule
you're not allowed to buy out the model
3 or the model y you have to turn your
leases in because they're going to reuse
it they're going to make money off you
they're not letting because they're so
high demand for it yeah so because of
that I had to turn in my Tesla now once
you go Tesla you are not going back so
you went from Tesla to Tesla yeah I'll
never go back to a gas car there's no
way a Honda Accord would have made sense
a Prius would have made sense I can
never see myself going to a gas station
and putting gas in my car but is this a
pro is this a humility issue no because
how much is the monthly payment on that
on my new car yeah
um 940 because that's pretty high well
my last one that I've been driving for
two years was 870. so it's you're you
see it as just a transfer just a
transfer although you have now I own the
car I bought it this is gonna be my
forever car
right this is mine now not leasing okay
and I'm proud of it and I know I'm gonna
work hard to sustain it my dad said the
same thing when I was driving here my
brother everybody in my family is
telling me the same thing my dad said
Yusuf you just bought a sixty seven
thousand dollar car like don't be stupid
this time because my dad was the number
one Advocate begging me not to buy the
Ferraris and I didn't listen to him but
I said Baba my payments were this much
now it's this much I promise you I got
this so and that's the only big purchase
I have to make everything else stays the
same in my life well it's too late now
it's not like you can return it yeah but
again I wouldn't have gone for gas
there's no way
no actually I returned my testers but I
have electric my Eva has a portion I
have a BMW okay why'd you return your
Teslas I personally think Elon Musk is a
I don't want to support him okay
financially and also
as much of a reason as that is uh I'm
really curious about all the EV Tech
coming out like like all these Brands
all these car companies are coming out
with these amazing electric cars but the
way I see Tesla is like it's like the
apple of the [__] it's like if you're
gonna go electric I just see it well
they were the only one yeah so now but
it's so good superchargers God oh my car
dude my car charges at the there's a um
Electra Electrify America is the
charging stations that's for non-teslas
it's owned by Volkswagen dude my car
charges in like 10 minutes it's faster
than Tesla 10 minutes dude it's insane
like I go in use the bathroom I come
back it's done that's actually dude it's
mind-blowing I didn't know that because
Tesla they they up charge you for the um
the faster charge yeah they do these
guys just included the portion VFW wow
it's just included wow
so the technology is really cool and I'm
just I'm just really curious about what
else is out there also though yeah I
said I had a Tesla for two years I
didn't drive my car for two years why
Tesla drove itself
okay don't do don't rely too much on
that
I mean my eyes are on the road there's a
lot of people blowing up on the road
eyes are on the road but it drives
itself on the freeway I've gone from L.A
to San Diego and touching the steering
wheel just off the exits right on the
freeway yeah yeah it is fun by the way
my BMW has the same [__] Ah that's what
do you think you think that Tesla's got
the the corner on all this [__] and they
did for a long time but these guys who
are working on it now these are like car
Juggernaut yeah these people know well
at least we're on the same page I think
electric is where it's going oh yeah
it's gonna be yeah I agree that I
I would have a hard time uh it just
feels like you're going backwards
getting a gas you know what I mean I
wish they came out with a cyber truck
though the Halo warthog that looks so
cool
yeah
that's Elon Musk for you yeah
well anyway
listen guys it's been a great time Lucy
thank you for being here I wish you the
best thank you thank you all of you
every single one of you here I never
thought in a million years you guys
would like me I thought you guys hated
me for years we never hated you bro no
but well when you have a victim
mentality when the internet hates you
you think everybody hates you and H3
like we're haters you said some stuff
before yeah I mean look I am a notorious
hater so I don't I don't I'm not
surprised that you thought that yeah so
the fact that this love like I was
genuinely caught off guard but thank you
guys your supporters have literally been
the most supportive group in my chats
ever awesome like there's a woman named
Betty Davis one night she gifted me like
over 300 Subs wow shut up Betty where's
my Shadows Betty yeah with peace and
love bro get them over here first then
go to then go to fousey yeah thank you
Betty just kidding guys go give um
fousey your your primes it's free
all right bro keep it grounded thank you
I will let's go the long time this time
and don't give those hater ass [__]
[__] anything to be like see this
happen again yeah you know what I mean
oh my God it's good for you bro proud of
you thank you brother and thanks for
being so honest I think that that's
special no thank you for giving me the
platform and being respectful towards
what I shared you could have taken a
whole different route I shared some
vulnerable [__] no I want to learn I'm
here to learn to listen
okay I'm not such a [__] hater ass
[__] all the time just 90 of the time
let me see that hairline before we go
you want to feel it kind of you have to
so this is a tattoo yeah oh my God bro
what shaved this morning
feels like my ball sack does it a little
bit you don't have hairs on your ball no
I do but the skin it's very like oh yeah
it's very sensitive come back here
wow yeah it's so it tastes like beef
jerky it tastes like beef jerky no no it
looks good A woman literally on stream
came up to me and they they can vouch
for me and she said it's a really nice
haircut thank you
so do you regret the the hair tattoo oh
100 you do yeah what the [__] I have a
tattoo on my head the [__] you think I
like being on the first date I have to
do it first date that's my rule I'm not
gonna make her what do you say how do
you tell them I just take off my hat and
I say you know this is a tattoo I just
own it dude they get weirded up I love
it oh they love it I love it not love I
think more the honesty than anything but
they're not weirded out by it so you go
just so you know this is a tattoo and I
come in five seconds
I don't tell them that right away we
gotta get there
all right bro thanks for coming in thank
you guys uh
uh
I'll be I'll be straight up with you
guys
I think it's 50 50 on tomorrow
why is that because I I'm feeling like I
might need to rest
oh
like I came in my throat was feeling
scratchy last night I woke up feeling
I did a covid test I don't have coven I
don't feel super sick right you could
tell look at it you're not super yeah
I'm not trying to infect anybody but I
feel something happening
I love how you say that right after he
just grabbed his head
yeah I feel this well he didn't shake my
hand when he first came in he said I
have to take it you might want to wash
your Dome
I do I do I shave it every day no I can
feel that next time I come I'm bringing
muffin by the way I still can't believe
it guys Ethan I texted him can I bring
muffin she's a five pound teacup Maltese
he goes I don't know how the two dogs
would react to her they're very feisty
yeah because the last and if she's like
a sweet little Rottweilers here and
there was two tiny these dogs Shredder
will and Alfredo too when when he gets
going they'll go after any dog
regardless of size so if the dog is
smaller than them they'll try they're
gonna try to kill your dog I'm sorry bro
she can hold her own muffin she got
taken by a coyote and survival oh my God
yes terrified wait what happened my mom
ever so scared when I stay with my mom
she lets muffin out every morning so one
morning muffin muffin jumps off my bed
goes downstairs mom opens the door not
30 seconds later I hear a shriek from my
mom that a mom only gives when her son
dies yeah I immediately in boxers get
out of bed run outside the neighbors
crying coyote just took your dog oh no
we start chasing the neighbors chased
first and it was a baby coyote took
muffin and the two parents were watching
we're looking we can't find her I
already my heart was gone I thought she
was gone as we're walking home my dad
goes let's check this alley we go down
the alley you hear she's under the car I
don't go look because I think my dead
dog is under the car the neighbor runs
up she's bleeding and crying but the
neighbor goes and gets his car pulls up
to me because I'm I'm stuck in shock
yeah and he goes get in the car we're
going to the vet takes her to the vet
she survives wow
what a champion if the puncture if it
was like the adult coyotes she would
have been gone because you saw the two
she's five pounds I mean yeah you see
the two punctures in her neck but it
wasn't deep enough to so the vet she she
was there she just got stitches and she
was able to heal yeah oh my God that's
so scary yeah I would have lost my
second dog dollar died when he was three
my teacup Yorkie you know people were
saying you killed your dog for clout
that's crazy
that's that's hurtful that was my first
dog my mom didn't only have a kid a dog
so vicious about it dollar was my first
dog I love dollar with every he's
tattooed on my [__] arm no I have the
same love for my dogs you know what I
mean so
that seems crazy
I'm glad your dog's okay man thank you
next time I'm bringing her okay if she
survived the coyote Survivor yeah thank
you so much all right bro thank you have
a good stream be good
yeah so I'll let you guys know if I'm
gonna
I'm gonna try to make it tomorrow
hopefully I'll be I'll be feeling better
I'm gonna rest tonight but I'll
definitely be back on Friday
from hell or high water
do we have anything on Friday going on
to say uh uh
uh
Friday this Friday
um what do we have Let's see we have
um
uh we have an ad planned and very
exciting that's about all that's on the
agenda well we have a great episode I
swear to God
actually I think we have something
pretty fun that we're maybe doing on
Friday I don't know well that is not in
the Scorpion Chair by the way huh Dan is
not in the Scorpion Studio has been
reshuffled we'll talk about that it
finally happened or tomorrow anyway guys
thank you thank you with peace and love
this is a serious message thank you for
watching and I'll see you guys either
tomorrow or Friday
till then thank you guys
[Music]